EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU AND
WELCOME. TWO OF THE FOURTH
HEARING. ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON POLICE REFORM MY
NAME IS MIKE GIPSON I SERVE AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON POLICE REFORM.
HERE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING CHORES
THAT MUST GO OVER. SO ONE OF
BEG YOUR INDULGENCE WHILE I
PROCEED IN READING THE
HOUSEKEEPING CHORES. THANK WILL
GOVERN THIS MEETING. DUE TO THE
CONTINUOUS STAYED HOME ORDER.
WE ARE WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AT THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
ROOM IN PERSON. WE ALSO REQUIRE
THAT MASK THE WARRANT AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING- BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
IN PERSON IN THE HEARING ROOM
OR AT OUR VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASS
A MASS WILL BE PROVIDED FOR YOU.
BECAUSE OUR SPACE IS LIMITED WE
HAVE SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SITTING ON THE DIESS THEY'LL BE
JOINING ME SOON AND OTHERS WILL
BE SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE
POSSIBLY- AND FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
SPEAKING OF FROM THE AUDIENCE
WE ASK THAT YOU OPPOSE THE
MICROPHONE BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS
AND PLEASE AGAIN REMEMBER TO
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
DURING THAT PERIOD. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC. WHEN WE REACH THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF THE
AGENDA. I WOULD ASK THAT ANY
PERSONS OR ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE IN THE
MEETING ROOM PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE ONE PERSON AT A
TIME PLEASE MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE HEARING ROOM I WOULD ASK
THAT THE THAT THE PUBLIC DO NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. JUST FEEL
FREE TO ASK ONE OF THE
SERGEANTS THEY WOULD JUST IT TO
YOUR OF SPECIFIED- LEVEL. ALL
RIGHT YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE WITH
PARTICIPATING WITH YOUR
PROVIDING YOUR COMMENTS OR
RETURN BACK TO YOUR SEAT.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME PANELISTS. AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAKING
USE OF ONE OF OUR- WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL AND OR- AROUND
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY- STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE GROUNDS OF THE
CAPITOL IN A FEW LOCATIONS AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THOSE
WITNESSING THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING
ROOM AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATOR TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC'S
COMMENTS. THE CALL IN NUMBER
PLEASE WRITE THIS DOWN THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THE HEARING ROOM
I'LL REPEAT IT. IT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN AREA CODE. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN ONCE
AGAIN AREA CODE. 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE WITH IMPORTANT.
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO ONCE AGAIN. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO ZERO TWO YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON
YOUR TV SCREEN THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW. TO BE
PLACE IN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS. IF YOU
ARE CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART DEVICE
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION. WE
MAY NEED TO LIMIT- HALL LONG
ARE EACH SPEAKER FROM THE
PUBLIC DURING A PUBLIC COMMENT-
SPEAKS BUT WE WILL LET YOU KNOW
AND ADVISE YOU ACCORDINGLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND COOPERATION
AND GOVERN YOURSELVES TO THESE
BRIEF REMARKS ON THE CAR. SO
WITH THAT AGAIN I'M MIKE GIPSON
I REPRESENT THE SIXTY FOR THE
STATE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND I
CHAIR THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
POLICE REFORM THERE IS A WHICH
I REPRESENT. OUR WANTS WILL OF
BROOKE COMPTON CARSON
WILMINGTON NORTH LONG BEACH
LYNWOOD GARDENA TORRANCE. AND
I'M HAPPY TO REPRESENT. THE
RESIDENTS OF THE SIXTY FOR THE
SIMPLY DRIFTING. FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE TRACKED THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE. HEARING IN HIS WORK
OVER THE LAST YEAR I WANNA SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
FOR CONTINUING TO DEDICATE YOUR
TIME WITH ME AND MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE IT REVEALS YOUR
COMMITMENT TO SEEKING JUSTICE
AND THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
FOR OTHERS LET ME PROVIDE A
RECAP OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE THUS FAR. WE HAVE HELD
THESE HEARINGS BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITY HAVE DEMANDED CHANGE
IN RESPONSE TO THE POLICE
MISCONDUCT THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND COUNTRY AT
LARGE. WE HEAR YOU WE SEE YOU
WE THANK YOU FOR EXPRESSING
YOUR- THE THANK YOU FOR
EXPRESSING YOUR- CONCERNS AND
GIVING US THE SPACE TO ADDRESS
THESE CASES. WHILE WE HAVE
LOOKED AT A TRUE COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM WE THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
THOSE THOSE OFFICERS WHO DO THE
WORK IN GOOD FAITH AND COMMIT
THEMSELVES TO THEIR CAREER AND
SERVING OUR COMMUNITY EXPRESSLY
DURING THESE ONGOING TIMES OF
THE PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA IS
CONTINUING TO LEAD OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT REFORM LAST YEAR.
OUR FIRST HEARING WAS THAT HE
WAS THERE ON THE HISTORY OF
POLICE REFORM EFFORTS I SECOND
HERE HEARING ADDRESS
RECRUITMENT AND TRAINING. OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ALONE THE
CITIZENS THE TYPICAL ASIAN
PROCESS AND THE THIRD HEARING
WAS ON POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY
DISCIPLINE AND THE DEPARTMENTS
LEVEL. AND THROUGH LITIGATION.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL REGARD THE
DAMAGES THE DAMAGE THAT POLICE
MISCONDUCT INFLICTS ON THE
COMMUNITY AND HOW COMMUNITIES
RECOVER FROM POLICE MISCONDUCT.
WELL HERE WE'LL HEAR FROM-
THOSE WHO WORK TOWARDS
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY POLICE
MISCONDUCT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING THE FAMILIES OF
INCLUDING THE FAMILY OF ANGELO
PEOPLE WHO WAS TRAGICALLY
KILLED BY POLICE IN ANTIOCH
CALIFORNIA IN DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR EXPERTS ON VICTIMS
COMPENSATION AND LEGAL REMEDIES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE PANEL FOR BEING WITH US IN
THE AUDIENCE WITH THOSE OR
WATCHING AS WELL AS LISTENING
HERE TODAY. FOR THE AUDIENCE.
YOU WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF OUR
HEARING DURING THE DESIGNATED
TIME FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION. BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUES- WHO
ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND
THANK THEM FOR JOINING ME AND
HOLDING THIS HEARING ON THIS
IMPORTANT SUBJECT MATTER. I NOW
LIKE TO INVITE MY COLLEAGUES.
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE TO SELL PRODUCE
THEMSELVES- AND HAVE A FEW
REMARKS BEFORE WE START. AND
THEN WE HAVE THOSE WHO ARE HERE
IN THE ROOM AND THEN WE HAVE
SOME WHO JOINED US VIRTUALLY
WHO WILL ALSO BE JOINING US
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. AND WILL BE
ABLE TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AS
WELL. I GET OLYMPIC MEMBERS
TAKING TIME OUT HIS BUSY
SCHEDULE FOR CHAMPING THIS AND
BEING PART OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON A PAUSE NOW AND I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUE
WHO'S ON THE DIETS WITH ME.
MISTER TOM LACKING FOR OPENING
REMARKS AND COMMENTS MADAKI.
THANK YOU IT CERTAINLY IS AN
HONOR TO BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
MISTER NON ALSO THE HEARING.
OKAY YEAH MY NAME IS TOM LACKEY
ON THE VICE CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY. I SPENT
TWENTY YEARS CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL- PROUD TO BE PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION I HOPE WITH
SOME MEANINGFUL. ON THE FLOOR
TO ADDRESS THE VERY VERY GOOD
ISSUES IN THE ABOUT. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH MISS LACKEY WE HAVE
SOME WHO ARE JOIN ON THE PHONE
I SEE OUR MAJORITY LEADER-
MISSPELLING WAIT AT LEAST RAMOS.
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE UP
SO THAT. ISRAEL'S CAN HAVE HER
COMMENTS. YES ONE MOMENT. OKAY
YOU CAN START TALKING OUT.
ELOISE REF. OKAY STE OBTALA WE
CAN JUST SEE NOW WE CAN HEAR
YOU. WE'LL GET IT TOGETHER. YOU
CAN START OUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S
SUCH AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH
YOU AND I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC IT'S ABOUT
AFFECTING SO MANY SO MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY FOR SO LONG AND
HAVING THIS SPACE TO TALK ABOUT
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
IT TO HAVE YOU INVITED TO THE
VARIOUS MEMBERS ACHIEVE
INVITED. I AM VERY PLEASED TO
BE HERE AND I LOOK LOOK FORWARD
TO LEARNING MORE DURING TODAY'S
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS ON
THE LINE- I UNDERSTAND THAT-
OUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUDY SALAS IS JOINED US. OKAY
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS.
ONE MOMENT THAT'S. WE ALSO HAVE
MISSED GONZALEZ REINA GONZALEZ
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US AND YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR REMARKS. OKAY SHE'LL BE
JOINING US IN A FEW MOMENTS SO
WE'LL JUST PROCEED AS SOON AS
SHE'S ON- WE'LL JUST ASK THE
TEAM TO NOTIFY ME SO WE CAN
HAVE HER PROVIDE SOME OPENING
REMARKS AND COMMENTS AS WELL.
AGAIN WOULD TAKE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING US IN
PERSON AS WELL AS VIRTUALLY. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
MEMBERS WILL BE COMING IN AND
OUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE TODAY'S
GOOD FRIDAY WE THANK THOSE- FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE AND JOINING US. NOW
WE'RE WE WILL HEAR FROM- OUR
PANELISTS. WHO WILL SPEAK ABOUT
THE DANGER THAT POLICE
MISCONDUCT INFLICTS ON THE
COMMUNITY. EACH PANELIST. WILL
HAVE UP TO SIX TO EIGHT MINUTES
TO SPEAK. AND WILL- PRESENTS IN
THE ORDER NOTED ON THE AGENDA.
BEFORE PRESENTING WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND THEN PROCEED. WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ALL REMARKS.
WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM OUR FIRST.
PAN OUR PRESENTERS THE FAMILY
OF ANGELO CANCEL WILL INTRODUCE
AND ASKED TO COME UP THE
STEPFATHER ROBERT COLLINS
STEPFATHER OF ANGELO PINTO. AND
THEN SANDRA CANTIL COLLINS
MOTHER AND THEN BALLOT COLLINS
SISTER WHO ALL WILL OR IN
PERSON HERE TODAY AND THIS IS
THE FAMILY OF ANGELO CAN TELL
WHO WILL PROVIDE A TESTIMONY
AND THEIR PRESENTATION SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID- PLEASE IN
ADDITION SELF AND STATE YOUR
NAME. AND THEN PROCEED. YOU FOR
INVITING US TO BE. ARAMBULA IF
YOU CAN SPEAK A BLOWOUT I AM
BALLOT- AND LOOKING DOES
SISTER- CASSANDRA KEEP A
CALLING ANGELES SMALL. AND I AM
ROBERT COLLINS- I IMAGINE LOW
CANDICE'S STEPDAD ALTHOUGH HE
CALL ME DAD. YES SO FOR IT JUST
A BIT OF BACKGROUND YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I CALL IN CUI ANGELO WAS
EXPERIENCING AN EPISODE OF
EXTREME PARANOIA ON THE NIGHT
OF- TALKING TO WHAT DECEMBER
TWENTY THIRD. AND HE
EXPERIENCED THIS BEFORE- WE
WERE NOT. AS PATIENTS PATIENT
ON THAT NIGHT AS HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY AND THAT ENDED UP
EXACERBATING HIS FEARS- WHICH
IN TURN LEAD MY MOTHER NINE TO
PANIC FOR OURSELVES. M. AS HE
HELD IT TOGETHER AND- BECAUSE
MY DAD WAS HE WAS FAR AWAY I
DECIDED MY ONLY CHOICE. HAD
BEEN TO CALL THE POLICE FOR
HELP. WHEN THEY ARRIVED QUICKLY.
THE FIRST TWO OFFICERS SMALL.
TO SEE ME RESTRAINING IN A BEAR
HUG ON THE FLOOR CHEST TO CHEST
HE MADE NO MOVE TO ESCAPE FROM.
I THINK BEING THIS IS WHAT HE
NEEDED. THE OFFICERS PROCEEDED
WITH THE CALL WITH EVEN FOR
BECAUSE IT LOOKED LIKE I WAS IN
CONTROL. HE TOOK FROM MY ARM
THE SESSION HERE. AND ON THE
WAY DOWN HE SAID TOWARD IF
PLEASE DON'T KILL ME. DID THE
NONPROFIT. ONE OFFICER ACROSS
HIS LEGS AND PUSH THEM TOWARDS
HIS BODY. IN THE OTHER OFFICER
PUT HIS FEET ON THE BACK OF
FEDERAL RULES THAT. THEY HAD
SOME DIALOGUE WITH ME DURING
WHICH WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE ANGELO
DID NOT BELONG IN JAIL. BECAUSE
HE WAS HAVING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. BUT THEY DID NOT CHECK
A NONCHALANT. I ASK SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES. FOR USE QUESTIONS.
THE TWILIGHT DECEIVE THEY COULD
CHIP. BUT THEY DID NOT. AFTER
WHORL THE OFFICER THAT HAD HIS
KNEE AND WEIGHT ON ABSOLUTE
RETIRED IN THE ANOTHER OFFICER.
DO KIDS POLICE ONCE THE
PARAMEDICS ARRIVED THE REMOVED
THEIR WAIT FOR AVENGERS THE ACT
AS THEY TURN THEM OVER HE WAS
LIAM LEADING FROM HIS MOUTH ANY
TH ICE ROLLED UP IN HIS HEAD HE
LOOKED DEAD. THE PROCEEDED TO
REMOVE THE HEAD COACH AND
WITHOUT PERFORMING CPR
PROCEEDED TO PUT HIM ON SOME
KIND OF BLANKET OR TARP. AND
MOVE HIM TO A GURNEY WHERE THEY
BEGIN THE CPR THEY TOOK HIM TO
THE HOSPITAL. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CONDUCT OF THE OFFICERS WAS
UNNECESSARY FOR TWO MAIN
REASONS- FIRST THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE AS A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS WHICH REQUIRES DE%
ESCALATION AND SPEAKING TO THE
PERSON EXPERIENCING IT- AND
SECOND HE WAS COMPLIANT
NONVIOLENT. AND ABLE TO BE
RESTRAINED BY MY MOM- SO SOON
WE WERE TAKEN TO THE POLICE
STATION. WHERE WE WERE KEPT FOR
HOURS BEFORE WE WERE QUESTIONED
AT ABOUT FOUR AM WE WERE DRIVEN
BACK TO OUR HOUSE BUT WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED. INTO THE HOUSE UNTIL
AFTER NINE AM. AMONG THE MANY
PEOPLE INSIDE THE HOUSE WERE
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AND
DETECTIVES. WORKING TOGETHER IN
TEAMS OF TWO ONE ANTIOCH POLICE
DETECTIVE AND ONE DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY- THEY WERE
TAKING TURNS ASKING MY OTHER
BROTHER AND MY DAD- WHAT HAD
HAPPENED OR JUST QUESTIONS
ABOUT MY BROTHER COLANGELO. AND
AMONG- EXCUSE ME DURING THIS
TIME THEY PREVENTED US FROM
SPEAKING TO THE DOCTORS TO
LEARN ABOUT THE STATE OF MY
BROTHER- AND THAT WENT ON FOR
AS LONG AS THEY COULD AMONG THE
MIXED ASSURANCES THAT HE WAS
OKAY ONE OFFICER SAID HE WAS
NOT DEAD YET AT THE STATION
AFTER TELLING US WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO GET IN CONTACT WITH HIS
DOCTORS ANOTHER RUSHED MY
MOTHER OFF THE PHONE WHEN THE
DOCTOR HAD CONTACTED US- AND
ONE MORE OFFICER TOLD US HE'D
SEEN MY BROTHER AND HE WAS FINE
AFTER THE DOCTOR HAD ALREADY
TOLD US. I'M SURPRISED HE'S
EVEN ALIVE- WE THINK THAT WE
DESERVED ACCESS TO ALL
INFORMATION POSSIBLE- ACCESS TO
THE DOCTORS AND MEDICAL
INFORMATION OUTSIDE OF INVOICES
AND WHAT THE OFFICERS ARE ON
THE RECORD OF SAYING HAPPENED
THAT NIGHT. ANGELES THIRTY
YEARS OLD AND HE OFFICIALLY
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SIX. HOWEVER ACCORDING TO THE
DOCTOR HE HAD ALMOST NO BRAIN
ACTIVITY AND HAD ONLY A VERY
FAINT PART B. THREE FOUR X. HE
HAD NO OTHER REFLEXES ARE
ATOMIC RESPONSES. HE WAS KEPT
MEDICALLY ALIVE BUT BY MAYBE
SIXTEEN DIFFERENT DRUGS WHICH
KEPT HIS HEART BEATING. BUT HIS
ORGANS WERE DYING AND MUCH OF
HIS BRAIN WAS DEAD HE WAS LABOR
NEVER ABLE TO BRIEF ON THE
PHONE. SINCE THE OFFICER HAD
KEPT HIM UNDER COULD BEAR
WEIGHT HAD NO GAG REFLEX AND
HE'S ICE COULD NOT CLOSE HE'S
HOW HE'S- ALWAYS HAD TO BE
TAPED SHUT. HE DIED AT THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE I TRUSTED.
DURING A TIME OF WHILE THE BIRD
WILL THEIR ABILITY. PEOPLE WE
LET INTO OUR HOUSE TO HELP.
REFORM MUST INCLUDE A BROADER
FOCUS A SWOLLEN CHANGING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ON MENTALLY
IMPAIRED INCIDENTS. IT'S VERY
PAINFUL PAINFUL IS IT IS TO
HAVE LOST MY SON WITNESSING IT
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO STOP IT
KNOWING IT WAS PREVENTABLE IS
ANOTHER LEVEL OF PAIN.
WITNESSING HOW WE WERE TREATED
TO AFTERWARDS WITH NO ACCESS TO
ANY INFORMATION AND THE ENERGY
OF DECEIT. IT'S ANOTHER LEVEL
OF PAIN. WE BELIEVE THE
OFFICERS NEED TO BE PENALIZED
WHEN THEY DON'T FOLLOW THEIR
TRAINING REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER
OR NOT. THE DA FLAMES THAT THE
CRIME WAS COMMITTED. NO THE
ONLY AM ARE YOU JUST. THE BILL
OF THIS LOSS EVERY BIG THE- I
AM WELL RAGE AT THE WAY. THE
APPEAR TO BLAME THE- OF CITY.
IT IS FRUITFUL THE- FROM MY
WRIST IS REGIS HE DOES UNDER
THEIR HELLO MY AGE. THANK YOU.
THANK THANK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONIES.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATES OUR- YOU
MAKE YOUR WAY TO- TESTIFY AND
PROVIDE YOUR EXPERIENCE. WHAT
HAPPENS TO- ANGELO. THANK YOU
ALL THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL NOW
HEAR FROM OUR SECOND PANELIST
TANYA FAISON OF PRESIDENT OF
BLACK LIVES MATTER HOW
SACRAMENTO WHO IS PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY- MISPLACED ARE YOU
WITH THIS. I AM WITH YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU
VERY MUCH YOU CAN FOR SIX TO
EIGHT MINUTES- I WON'T TAKE
THAT LONG IT'S REALLY HARD TO
COME AFTER A FAMILY THAT JUST
TOLD THEIR STORY AND THEIR
STORY IS EVERYTHING. THIS STORY
IS EXACTLY WHAT'S WRONG- MY
NAME IS TANYA FAISON WITH BLACK
LIVES MATTER SACRAMENTO- HEY I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING ME IN THE
SPACE AGAIN- LAST TIME I EIGHT
HITS AND EXPLAIN THAT YOU KNOW
LAST TIME THAT I WAS WITH THIS
THIS. IS COMMITTEE AND
EXPLAINED THAT- I'M WITH THE
LIMIT ABOLITIONIST ORGANIZATION
WE ARE ABOLITIONIST WE DO
BELIEVE IN REFORMS THAT LEAN
INTO A COMMUNITY- THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF TIMES WHY HAVE YOU
KNOW LOCKED INTO THE CAPITAL.
AND MET WITH DIFFERENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OR SENATORS. AND YOU
KNOW PARK MY CAR PAY FOR
PARKING WALKING TO THE- CAPITOL
LOOK FOR THE ROOM. SAT DOWN FOR
A FIFTEEN MINUTE MEETING AND
THEN LEFT AND SOMETIMES NOTHING
EVER COMES FROM IT SO I JUST
WANT TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT-
YOU KNOW THAT THE ENERGY OF
THESE FAMILIES COMING IN AND
TELLING THEIR STORIES AND
PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT WORKING
COMMUNITY COMING IN AND GIVING
OUR IDEAS AND OUR- OUR CONCERNS
I JUST YOU KNOW I WANT THEM TO
BE HELD VERY IMPORTANT I GUESS
THAT'S THE WORD I WANT TO USE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE.
REAL EFFECTIVE CHANGE THAT
COMES FROM THESE MEETINGS-
BECAUSE IT IS A LOT OF ENERGY
IN PLACE COMING INTO THE SPACES
AND IT'S BEING RE LIT SO I JUST
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT
BECAUSE- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
SEE SOME CHANGES- I KNOW THAT
THIS. COMMITTEE MEETING IS
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT.
AND THAT HAS ON FAMILIES WHEN
FOLKS ARE ABUSED OR KILLED BY
POLICE- I KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
TO TALK ABOUT WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT. DIFFERENT DIFFERENT WAYS
OF. OF GETTING JUSTICE- AND
IT'S JUST THOSE THOSE TOPICS
ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE SEE A LOT OF. BILLS THAT ARE
CREATED- THAT YOU KNOW START
OFF BEING REALLY STRONG AND
POWERFUL WOMAN TO GET WATER
DOWN. WE SEE POLICIES LOCALLY
AND I LOCAL GOVERNMENTS STATE
GET PUT INTO- THAT YOU KNOW GET
PUT INTO. THE BECOME POLICY AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
REPERCUSSIONS ATTACHED TO THEM
SO THEY GET VIOLATED. AND THERE
IS NO. YOU KNOW THERE IS NO.
THERE IS NO. THERE'S NOTHING
THERE THAT THAT MAKE SURE THAT
THESE THINGS DON'T GET VIOLATED
OR THAT THESE OFFICERS DON'T
CONTINUE TO REPEAT. THE SAME
THINGS OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO I
JUST WANT I WANT TO BRING THOSE
THINGS UP BECAUSE- THERE IS A
LOT OF- FLOW CHANGE. THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING SINCE STEPHON
CLARK'S DEATH I'LL SAY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN I'VE SEEN THE MOST
REACTION FROM. LEGISLATORS AND-
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND APPOINTED
OFFICIALS AND POLICE CHIEFS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO- WE ARE
STILL EXPERIENCING THESE ABUSES
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS JUST IN THE
pSOMETIMES MOST OF THE TIME THEY
ARE IN THE FORM OF. ABUSE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES- SO I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT AS WELL I KNOW
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN I KNOW A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
HARASSED A NUMBER OF TIMES AND
CONTINUE TO BE TARGETED ON A
REGULAR BASIS JUST FOR EXISTING
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. SO I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT- I REALLY I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING ELSE TO SAY
EXCEPT FOR TO HOLD- TO HOLD THE
FAMILY THAT WAS HERE BEFORE ME-
THEIR STORY WAS PAINFUL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MYSTERIES ON FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE- TODAY AND
NOT LIVES LET ME ASSURE YOU
THAT- THE COMMUNITIES VOICES
AND NOT FELT FALLING ON DEAF
EARS AS WELL WE HAVE THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING-
THAT'S WHY WOULD THERE'S ABOUT
TWENTY TWO PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- LOOKING AT RE
IMAGINING WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOOKS LIKE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND SO. WE'D
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR ACTIVISM
IN THIS SPACE. NEXT UP IF RANDY
WE WILL LIKE TO HEAR FROM OUR
THIRD PANELIST DR GE- JANA. OF
PRICE SHARKS A LICENSED
PSYCHOLOGIST SPECIALIZING IN
POLICE OF WILL BE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY. DR PRICE SHOPS ARE
YOU WITH US. I AM A FIRST
RESPONDER PSYCHOLOGIST THEY'VE
BEEN TREATING POLICE OFFICERS
FOR ABOUT TWENTY ONE YEARS AND-
I DO A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
BUFFET THERE'S LIKELY
DEBRIEFINGS AND AFTER SHOOTING
SITE TREAT A LOT OF PTSD- I
ALSO DID PRE EMPLOYMENT
EVALUATIONS- I ALSO RUN A NON
PROFIT THAT PROVIDES A LOT OF
THIRTY CLIENTS POSTED FAMILY.
AND AND TO SOMEONE FIRST AND
IT'S WELL AND I WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE NATIONAL
POLICE DECIDE FOUNDATION AND
THAT IS A NONPROFIT AGENCY THAT
IS- A RESOURCE. FOR OFFICERS
THAT ARE CERTIFIED ALL. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MANY DON'T KNOW
AND I'M SURE THE CAN IN IS
AWARE THAT. POLICE ARE ARE MORE
TO COMMIT SUICIDE THAN THEY ARE
TO DIE AND STRICT. WE HAVE
REALLY AN EPIDEMIC OF POLICE
OFFICERS WHO ARE COMMITTING
SUICIDE WHO ARE- IS SUFFERING
FROM SEVERE PTSD OFTEN TAKE
THEIR LIVES AFTER AFTER THEY'VE
RETIRED BECAUSE OF THE STRESS
AND TRAUMA OF THE JOB. AND I
CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT OVER A
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
OFFICERS I'VE WORKED WITH. I
BARELY HAVE FLED AND OFFICERS
WHO DOESN'T. REALLY LOVE THEIR
COMMUNITY BUT UNFORTUNATELY
OFFICERS ARE TAX WITH HAVING
THE SAME NERVOUS SYSTEM THAT
ALL OF THAT TAB AND
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THEY
HAVE LESS THAN A HALF A SECOND
TO MAKE VERY CRITICAL DECISIONS
THEMSELVES. SOMETIMES THOSE
DECISIONS ARE GOOD AND
SOMETIMES THEY'RE NOT SO GOOD
AND AFTERWARDS THEY SPEND THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES BEATING
THEMSELVES UP. AND IT'S ALWAYS
A TRAGEDY ALWAYS A TRAGEDY WHEN
SOMEBODY DIES IT'S ALWAYS A
TERRIBLE THING AND THEN THE
COST TO THE FAMILY OF THE
PERSON THAT THEY LIVE IT'S
HORRENDOUS BECAUSE TO THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS HORRIBLE- BUT ONE
STORY THAT WE NEVER HEAR IS THE
COST TO THE OFFICER- THAT HAVE
TO MAKE THAT JUDGMENT AND- THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I AM PRIVY TO
BECAUSE. I STANDS. MANY MANY
READING TREATING THESE AND
WOMEN IN LAW COURSE IT'S- WITH
THE STATE'S. AND HAVE NINE FROM
THEM HAVE SEVERE. THERE ARE FOR
OUR SAN THEY VERY I FEEL FROM
THE COMMUNITY- AND THEY THEY
KIND OF ENTER A PERSONAL HELP.
THAT THEY THEY REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY PLACE TO TURN TO
BECAUSE- UNLIKE OTHER PEOPLE
OFFICERS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
TALK TO THE MEDIA THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO PUT ANYTHING OUT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO TALK TO FRIENDS AND
RELATIVES YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
A BURDEN BECAUSE- FROM DAY ONE
IN THE ACADEMY THE TAX FELLOW
ADD- TAKING CARE OF ALL OF US.
AND DO THEY DO IT PERFECTLY
SOMETIMES AND SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T AND I AM VERY MUCH AWARE
OF THAT. BUT I WILL SAY THAT
MOST OF THEM THAT I HAVE MET
OVER THE YEARS TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY. BUT OVER THE YEARS
THE JOB DOES TEND TO CHIP AWAY
AT THEM AND THAT THEIR FAMILIES
AND THAT THE WELL BEING OF
THEIR FAMILIES. AND. IT'S SO.
SHE YOU KNOW IT'S VERY THAN
THEN BECAUSE TO THE MELA. WHERE
IN ANOTHER LANE- WITH THEY
DON'T- WORKING PEOPLE THAT THEY
DO YOU KNOW THAT IS THEIR THEIR
THERE TO. AND SUDDENLY OUT
THERE TASKED WITH. TRYING TO
DECIDE THEIR QUEUE FROM A
COMMUNITY MEMBER AND THEN OFTEN
THEIR THEY'RE ALSO TASKED WITH
DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND THEN
HAPPY TO RENDER AID- HE P. R.
ANY KIND OF DRUG RESUSCITATION
METHODS. AND SO THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT THEY LIVE
WITH HER FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES. AND IT'S NOT LIKE WHAT
IT'S LIKE ONLINE. MOVIE DURING
THE MOVIE CARE AND ONLY BUT
SQUARE OFFICERS JUST YOU KNOW
USE FORCE WHEN THEY. GO HOME
AND THEY'RE JUST FINE. I HAD
NEVER BEEN THAT TO BE THE CASE
AFTER WITH ME MANY MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE P. BUT I HAVE. IN
THERE. IS IN L. THERE ARE ONLY
AND THAT THE THAT MEANT HEALTH
WITH THE THEY THEY SHOULD LIKE
THAT GET OUT OF.AND SO I. WHAT
I WANTED EVERY TO NATALIE SAID
IT. IT'S PARTNERSHIP THAT THAT
IT VERY DIFFICULT PART. AND THE
WHAT SECOND IS ARE VERY TOUGH
AND HAVE A VERY LONG LASTING
IMPACT ON- ON THE OBJECT DURING
THE OFFICER'S FAMILY BUT ALSO
OBVIOUSLY ON THE COMMUNITY AND-
AND THE PEOPLE THAT LOST PEOPLE
DURING THAT. DURING THAT EVENT
SO IT'S- AN AREA THAT NEEDS. TO
BE LOOKED AT AND YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE SOME SOLUTIONS ARE
RESOLUTIONS ARE THINGS THAT CAN
BE DONE. BUT IT'S EVERYBODY IS
HURTING- WHEN. YOU SUCH COURSE
HAVE TO HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- DR PRICE SHARP FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE ASK THAT YOU JUST
STAND BY WE'LL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU- WHEN WE GET
DOWN TO OUR- QUESTIONS AND
ANSWER PERIOD SO WE CAN ASK YOU
TO PLEASE STAND BY- FOR THAT-
REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NEXT UP WE WILL HAVE A DOCTOR
PORTER ARE YOU WITH US. YOU ARE
WELCOME DOCTOR PORTER DOCTOR
PORTER IS THE SENIOR PASTOR. OF
THE GENESIS CHURCH HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO IS THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA- STATE
AND NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK. A
DOCTOR PORTER WILL BE JOINING
US VIRTUALLY IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
APPEARING YET ANOTHER TIME AND
YOU ARE WELCOME TO PROCEED
WHICH WITH YOUR PRESENTATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON- FOR
THIS INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY
BEFORE. OF THE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON POLICE REFORM TO
DISCUSS THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE ON
REFORM. FROM ISSUES OF POLICE
AUTHORITY- MY NAME IS AGAIN THE
TOP SUPPORT PORTER AND
PRESIDENT. OF THE SACRAMENTO
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL ACTION
NETWORK FORMER CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA. STATE NETWORKS
NETWORK- WE ARE ONE OF THE
LEADING CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NATION
FOUNDED BY THE REV AL SHARPTON.
PROMOTING A MOTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
OF GENDER THAT CLOSE TO ONE THE
FIGHT FOR ONE STANDARD OF
JUSTICE DECENCY AND EQUAL.
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE HAD
EXPERIENCE BEING COMMUNITIES
WHO UNDERGONE WELL I BELIEVE
THE MISUSE THE MISUSE AND THERE
ARE SAY ABUSE OF POLICE
AUTHORITY. NOT ONLY HERE
SACRAMENTO OVER STEPHON
CLARK'S. KILLING WELL ALSO MY
HOME STATE OF MINNESOTA WHERE
WITH THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLIGHT. IN BOTH CASES THE
RESULTS ARE THE SAME A
FRACTURED RELATIONSHIP. BETWEEN
OUR PEACE OFFICERS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEY ARE SWORN TO
PROTECT AND SERVE. THEIR LOSS
OF TRUST- HOPE AND A LOW MORALE
REGARDING POLICING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES THERE IS FOR YOUR
ASPIRATION TO THE POINT WHERE
THE COMMUNITY RESPONSES ALL
ALMOST ALWAYS. COMBATIVE
TOWARDS AUTHORITY. POLICE
MISCONDUCT MISCONDUCT CREATES
TRAUMA AND MENTAL ILLNESS. I
HAVE WITNESSED EXPERIENCED
FIRST HAND. WHICH I BELIEVE IS
BEING PLAYED OUT NATIONALLY
AFTER WATCHED THE TRIAL DURCH
OFTEN FOR THE KILLING OF GEORGE
FLOOR. CONDITIONS OF THIS
PLEASE MISCONDUCT COST
TAXPAYERS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR ACROSS THE COUNTRY
IN THE SOLOMON OF CIVIL
LAWSUITS AND LEGAL COSTS. THAT
COULD BE BETTER SPENT ELSEWHERE.
ALL SOCIETIES AFFECTED BECAUSE-
BECAUSE OF THEIR SEN OMINOUS
PRESENCE ALL COMMUNITIES IT ONE
PERSON IS ABUSED THE WHOLE
ENTIRE FAMILY FEELS THE PAIN.
POLICE ABUSE OF POWER IF THESE
DAMAGES TO OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT ABUSE
THEIR POWER IT CREATES
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS FEAR AND
MISTRUST MISTRUST DAY INDOORS
YEARS AFTER THE INCIDENT OCCURS
WHICH FURTHER TO GRACE THE
RELATIONS BETWEEN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. IF
SOMEONE IN A BLACK OR BROWN
COMMUNITY IS A BIG BOTH CRIME.
WE HAVE TO THINK TWICE ABOUT
CALLING THE POLICE WE'RE JUST
SAYING SINCE WE PAY HARD EARNED
TAX MONEY FOR THEIR SERVICE.
OUR FIRST THOUGHT IS. CAN WE
TRUST THEM. IT RECALL POLICE
WILL THEY ESCALATE OR NOT AND
YEAH- DE ESCALATE WHEN THEY
ARREST ME OR HURT ME OR OR
WORSE KILL ME YOU KNOW AND NOT
GET THE REAL PERPETRATOR AND
THIS TRAIN OF THOUGHT AS
BROUGHT ABOUT BY BAD POLICING
AND THE OVER USE OF FORCE IN
OUR BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
HI AGAIN HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS
FIRST HAND- I LIVE IN OAK GROVE
IS TO THE OUTSIDE OF
SACRAMENTO. ELEVEN THOUGH
PRETTY WELL TO DO NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND SOME YEARS AGO THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT THAT A RARE INCIDENT
OCCURRED RON NEED TO CALL THE
POLICE. AND WHEN I CALLED THEM
TO REPORT THE CRIME I FELT THE
NEED TO TELL THE DISPATCHER TO
LET THE POLICE NOW. AS SHE WAS
SENDING- THE POLICE THROUGH.
I'M A ENABLE. AND THE ONLY THE
HOUSE ARE BLACK. AND THAT WE
WERE NOT THE SUSPECTS. I WANT
TO MAKE THAT CLEAR BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I WAS
NOT GOING TO BE HURT OR
ARRESTED. OR NOT MY CHILDREN OR
MY WIFE WILL BE PERFORM RESTED.
OR BEAT UP OR SOMETHING SIDE
WAYS I'M I AM NOT ALONE. THE
IMPACT OF MISUSE OF AUTHORITY
IS THAT. WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THE TERMS. YOUR REAL BALLPARK
OF OUR LIVES BECAUSE KOHLI
BELIEVES MISSILES EVEN MORE
FEARFUL. ALL FOUR LINES. AND
THAT'S SIMPLY IS NOT HOW WE'RE%
SUPPOSED TO LIVE IN A CIVIL
SOCIETY. IS NO SIGNAL ALL OF.
THAT IS THE- TO BLACK PEOPLE
BLACK MEN AND WOMEN ARE STILL
PART AS THE BEST. AND BY LARGE
TEST AND I'M SORRY IT'S OKAY
HOW LAW ENFORCEMENT TREATS US.
FOR EXAMPLE IN SEVERAL POLICE
OFFICERS MURDERED STEPHON CLARK
THEY JUST OF BALTIMORE'S OWN.
MOTHER KIANA SUICIDE BY COP.
AND THE IMPACT OF SUCH RESULTED
IN THE WHOLE COMMUNITY
TRAUMATIZED FROM THE NIGHT OF
TERROR. AND HIS FAMILY FOREVER
STRUGGLING TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
ANY SENSE OF IT ALL. AND WE SEE
THE SAME DRAMATIC IMPACT DUE TO
POLICE MISCONDUCT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY REPEATEDLY YORK TO DO
THE TRUCK TO THE CHOKING OF
ERIC GARNER'S OPEN WITH OSCAR
GRANT. IN THE IN THE BAR
STATION THIS ALSO HOLDS TRUE TO
OVERSEE AND NOW WITH THEIR SHOP
AND A MINNEAPOLIS THE MONEY UP
THE MINNEAPOLIS POLICE OFFICER
WHO HELD HIS NAY ON GEORGE
PLACE NEXT BUT WHAT WE NOW
KNOW. TO BE NINE MINUTES AND
TWENTY NINE SECONDS HIS ACTIONS
HAS NOT ONLY TERRORIZE THE
FAMILY AND THE CITY. BY A TIRE
NATION. THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY. BECAUSE WE MUST CHANGE
DOES NOT. PASSED AWAY ONE
MINUTE FOR YOU. THANK YOU TO
STOP THE PRACTICE OF USING
POLICE OFFICERS TO DEHUMANIZE
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE AND
BRING FAIR UNBIASED POLICING
INTO BLACK AND BROWN
NEIGHBORHOODS SO THAT WE ALL
MAY BE SAFE AND SOMEDAY YOU
BRING ABOUT TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH DOCTOR PORTER WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR INSIGHT AS
WELL AS YOUR REMARKS- AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU CAN
JUST STAND BY- FOR A FEW
MOMENTS WE MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FROM OUR PANEL- AND
THOSE WHO HAVE ALSO JOINED AS
VIRTUALLY- FIRST OF ONE OVER
THE LINE UP TO HAVE A FEW
OPENING REMARKS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER RUDY SALAS.
WHO'S ON THE LINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THAT- YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING
THIS PALE TOGETHER AND- YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO HEAR NOT ONLY FROM THE
COMMUNITY BUT REALLY. THE FOCUS
ON THAT WHAT ARE THE NEXT STEPS
AND HOW DO WE PROCEED AND HOW
ARE WE GONNA. TRY TO RECTIFY
THE SITUATION AND SO I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR READERSHIP BUT-
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF- MEASURES NICK
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS BUT- I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS IT WIDE
TAKING TIME TODAY TO NOT ONLY
TESTIFY. HAD AND GIVE EXPERT
OPINIONS. ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT- TREAT THE
DIRECTIONAL. J. COME TO SOME
SORT OF. RESOLUTION WELL NOT
RESOLUTION BUT REALLY HOW TO
COME TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IS
WHETHER THAT'S VIA LEGISLATION
OR OR OTHER BEATS BUT PROCEDURE
LEADERSHIP. YOUR FROM EACH OF
OUR PANELISTS TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IMAGE SILENCE FOR
JOINING US THIS THIS MORNING
FOR THE SELECT COMMITTEE HERE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT WE WANT TO ADD WE HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL
ALL START AND THEN I'LL DEFER
TO ANY OF MY MEMBERS WILL START
WITH THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT
FIRST MR LACKEY IF YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS. AFTER ME THEN
I'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE TO
THOSE MEMBERS WERE JOINED AS
VIRTUALLY FURTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE PANEL SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID MY FIRST QUESTION IS FROM
FROM A COMMUNITY LANDS WHAT IS
THE NEED TO MAKE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHOLE AGAIN AND
CASES. OF POLICE. USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE AND MISUSE OF
MISUSING THEIR AUTHORITY- SO
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION. TO
DR- PRICE SHARP ARE YOU STILL
WITH THIS. I AM. IT SHOULD. I'M
I GUESS I COULD BE A LITTLE
CLARIFICATION OF WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING. ABSOLUTELY LET ME
REPEAT THE QUESTION AGAIN FROM
AND THIS IS ALSO FOR ANY OF THE
OTHER PANELS PENALISES WELL
FROM A COMMUNITY LANDS WHAT IS
THE NEED TO MAKE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES HOLD AGAIN IN
CASES OF POLICE. USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE AND MISUSING
THEIR AUTHORITY. WE'LL KEEP ALL
PRIVATE I THINK THAT FAMILIES
ONLY TO. WE NOW HAVE ASSISTANCE
AND THEY COULD BRING IN
RECOVERING FROM SOMETHING THAT
TRAGIC SO THAT IS THAT MY AREA
OF EXPERTISE BUT I THINK THAT.
ANY TIME A FAMILY LOSES A
FAMILY MEMBER IT'S A SEVERE
TRAGEDY AND THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED HELP AND ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
DOCTOR PORTER DID YOU HEAR THE
QUESTION YOU WANT TO ELABORATE
OR MISPLACED ON. FONG SURE I
BELIEVE THAT. YOU NOTE FROM THE
DOCTORS PRICE SERVICE- CORRECT
THE FAMILY DOES NEED SUPPORT-
THERE'S A TRAUMA THAT OCCURS.
ON TO THE FAMILIES- WHETHER IT
WAS ON. NO MATTER HOW THE-
BURKE GOES DARK OR CHARGES MATT
IS TO HAVE A FAMILY THAT LOST
OF A MEMBER OF THE FAMILY AND
THERE'S A TRAUMA THAT OCCURS
FOUNDERS AND THERE'S A NEED FOR
SUPPORT THESE FAMILIES ARE
OFTEN- PUT INTO A PLACE IN IN
PUBLIC- THAT THEY ARE NOT
PREPARED FOR YOU KNOW HAD ON
CNN THERE LONG BLOCK STATE AND
EVERYTHING AND THEY'RE NOT
PREPARED FOR IN ANY OF THIS.
AND JUST SEEING THEIR FIRST
HAND THEY DO NEED GUIDANCE IN
DEALING HELP IN THAT AND
THEY'LL BE- GOOD FOR THE STATE
TO COME IN TO SUPPORT THESE
FAMILY MEMBERS EITHER WAY NO
MATTER WHAT ALL HELLO ON. THE-
PERSON. YEAH OFTEN YES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PORTER-
ONE ASK ANOTHER QUESTION- WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE LARGEST
CONCERNS FOR RECOVERY WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE LARGEST A CONCERNS
OF FOR RECOVERY YOU KNOW THIS
MONEY- IS IT THAT BAD APPLES BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVING A
MARKET PLACE ON THE RECORD OR
HAVING CHARGES FILED AGAINST
THEM WHAT ELSE IS NECESSARY
AGAIN AS PART OF THE RECOVERY.
ASPECT WHEN- AN OFFICER- YES
MISUSED HIS OR HER AUTHORITY SO
AGAIN- WHAT IS A LARGE CONCERNS
FOR RECOVERY. THEY WON'T THAT
QUESTION YOU GUYS JUMP IN. I'D
LIKE TO I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS IT-
IF I CAN AND THEN ALSO THE
PREVIOUS QUESTION. IF POSSIBLE-
IN REGARDS AND I THINK IT'S I'M
I'LL BE ANSWERING BOTH
QUESTIONS AND WITH MY ANSWER- I
THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
NUMBER OF THINGS TO MAKE
FAMILIES FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
GETTING WHAT THEY NEED OUT OF-
THE SITUATION LIKE THE INCIDENT
THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED IT'S
GONNA THINK THEY'RE GONNA NEED
MENTAL HEALTH HELP. THEY'RE
GONNA NEED TIME TO BE ABLE TO
TRY TO HEAL AND BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES OF MONEY
FINANCIAL HELP- BUT THEY ALSO
NEED TO SEE JUSTICE. AND NO
JUSTICE MEANS NOT JUST WINNING
A LAWSUIT BUT IN ITS I'M NOT
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT LAWSUITS
I MEAN YOU KNOW WHATEVER THAT
FAMILY WANTS TO PURSUE IS WHAT
THEY SHOULD GET. BUT JUSTICE
MEANS THAT THE OFFICERS THAT
THAT GREW INTO THEIR TO THE
SITUATION THAT PUT THEM IN THE
SITUATION THEY NEED TO SEE SOME
TYPE OF- REPERCUSSIONS THEY
NEED TO SEE THAT THOSE OFFICERS
ARE PENALIZED. THAT THEY'RE
TREATED AS IF IT WAS BIKE IF I
GO OUT AND SHOOT SOMEBODY OR-
YOU KNOW PUT MY KNEE ON
SOMEBODY'S NECK UNTIL THEY DIE-
HOW WOULD I BE TREATED. WHAT I
HAVE TO I WOULD HAVE TO GO TO
THE COURTS I WOULD HAVE TO- YOU
KNOW HAVE A JURY LISTEN TO MY
TRIAL AND THEN I WOULD GET A
PUNISHMENT THAT. SEEMS
EFFICIENT FOR THE CRIME THAT I
COMMITTED SO I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE PROCESS THAT'S BEEN
MISSING AND THAT'S NEEDED. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE WHAT HELPS
HEAL FAMILIES IT WON'T NONE OF
THOSE THINGS. ALONE WORK I
DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK JUST
YOU KNOW SEEING. THE OFFICER GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS IS GOING
TO HELP HEAL THE FAMILIES BY
ITSELF. BUT IT ALL THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER ARE GOING TO HELP TO
BRING THOSE FAMILIES TO- TO A
BETTER SPACE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOES ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
ELABORATE ON THAT QUESTION- WE
WILL GO TO- HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE- WE SEE- MISTER
COLLINS- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON- YEAH I JUST TO. WANT TO
GET THE PERSPECTIVE THAT IT'S
BEYOND THE FAMILY I THINK WHAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IS SO MUCH
COMMUNITY SUPPORT- AND- BUT
IT'S ALSO BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY
ITSELF IS INJURED BY THIS
SITUATION I THINK WHAT WE NEED
FOR THAT IS A SENSE THAT THE
SYSTEM IS JUST A SENSE THAT THE
SYSTEM WILL INVESTIGATE ITSELF
AND CAN CORRECT ANY WRONGS- SO
FOR THE FAMILY THERE'S JUST
DON'T NORMAL GRIEVING BUT WHEN
YOU FEEL. THAT JUSTICE IS IN
BEING CARRIED OUT AND YOU CAN'T
TRUST A SYSTEM THAT MAKES THE
PAIN THAT MUCH GREATER BUT I
THINK IT'S NOT AGAIN JUST ABOUT
THE FAMILY I THINK IT'S ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY IN MANY WAYS WE
HAVE BEEN APPROACHED BY SO MANY
OTHER FAMILIES WHO HAVE NOT
COME FORWARD BEFORE WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN UP PUBLIC IN THEIR
SUFFERING- SO WE KNOW WE HAVE
MANY PEOPLE IN THE SAME
SITUATION BUT WHAT'S SHOCKING
IS. ONE OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT
WE HAD FROM PEOPLE THAT KNEW
ANGELO AND SOMETHING ABOUT ALL
OF THIS COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
ARE HAVING DOUBTS ABOUT THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AND I THINK
THAT THE NUMBER ONE THING WE
CAN DO FOR JUSTICE MAKING SURE
THAT WHEN THAT SYSTEM MAKES
MISTAKES WHEN THE IT NEEDS TO
CORRECT DIRECTION IT IS ABLE TO
DO SO IT DOESN'T CLOSE INTERNET
SOFT. AND JUST. ATTACKED JUST
QUO IT HAS TO. MAKE CHANGES
LIKE ANY SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
AND WE NEED A SYSTEM WE CAN
TRUST WE NEED A SYSTEM THAT WE
THINK IS JUST AND I THINK
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE. THINK
THAT YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T BRING
ANGELA BACK BUT THAT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING I THINK
FOR THE COMMUNITY TO HEAL. IS
TO BE ABLE TO REGAIN TRUST IN.
THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE- AND I
THINK FOR THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SOME REFORMS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT WE DON'T HAVE-
OFTENTIMES. THERE'S TOO MUCH.
OF IT YOU KNOW THEY'RE THERE
YOU KNOW WHAT WE WERE TOLD THIS
I'M SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND FOR
THE COVER UP THAT ONE SUIT.
THIS OF THE MESSAGES WE'VEGOTTEN FROM OTHER FAMILIES- AND-SO WERE. WERE A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED MORE THAN A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED THAT THE SYSTEM ITSELF
WON'T BE ABLE TO CORRECT. ITS
OWN PROBLEMS AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARINGS AND- AND BRING THIS
ISSUES THAT ARE REALLY
DIFFICULT FORWARD- YOU KNOW
THEIR BABY DOUBLE DIGITS FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED THE POLICE
OFFICERS. AND THE FAMILIES BUT
WE NEED A SYSTEM THAT CAN THAT
CAN RECTIFY ITSELF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE'RE HERE.
WE'RE HERE TRYING TO. SEE HOW
WE CAN CORRECT THE SYSTEM. AND
MAKE THE SYSTEM BETTER- I WANT
TO GO TO OUR LINE WE HAVE A
MAJORITY LEADER- MISS ELOISE
RASCAL I'M SORRY JUST HOLD ON
ONE MOMENT I WANTED TO FOR TO-
I WANNA GO TO MISTER TOM LACKEY
WAS WITH US. AND THEN I'LL GO
TO MYSTERIOUS. THERE'S A REASON
THAT- THIS PROBLEM HAS EXISTED
FOR A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
TIME THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING ON MANY
FRIENDS BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH SUCH A VERY VERY
DELICATE EMOTIONS YOU'RE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH FEAR YOU'RE
DEALING WITH- ANGER AND OFTEN
TIMES VIOLENCE. AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS I THINK THINGS COULD
BE MIS CHARACTERIZED
MISUNDERSTOOD BECAUSE OF THE
VOLATILITY OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BUT WHAT I THINK
IS VERY VERY VERY VITAL IS THAT
WE- WE'RE ABLE TO OPENLY. SB
TRANSPARENT FROM BOTH SIDES AND
BE SYMPATHETIC TO BOTH SIDES
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S WHEN YOU
GET REMEDY- IF IT IF IT BECOMES
TOO LOPSIDED. THEN I THINK
SOMETIMES OUR VISION GETS
BLURRY SO I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN HAVE CLARITY AND THAT WE
CAN BE HONEST AND THAT WE CAN
HAVE MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE
TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN HILL
BECAUSE WHAT WE DID IS BRIDGE.
BUT THAT'S REALLY I HOPE WHAT
EVERYBODY IS SEEKING- AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO BE A PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION AND PART OF
THAT BRIDGE BECAUSE IT REALLY
IS. CRITICAL THAT WE BRIDGE
THIS RELATIONSHIP THAT IS SO
FRACTURED.
MISTER. I CANNOT
HEAR YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE FAMILY OF.
ANGELO CAN GO- SPECIFICALLY FOR
HIS MOTHER. AND I APPRECIATE SO
MUCH THAT YOUR COURAGE TO BE
HERE AND TO SHARE YOUR PERSONAL.
EXPERIENCE AYE I HONESTLY
CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT WOULD YOU
HAVE GONE THROUGH. AND I THINK
THAT FOR ME I WANT TO HEAR
SPECIFICALLY FROM YOU. EIGHT
WHAT- WHAT COULD HAVE HAPPENED
IS THAT- EXCESSIVE FORCE
CLEARLY THAT YOU HAVE SHARED.
OTHER HAS BEEN DISCUSSION ABOUT
HAVING MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS COME ON THESE
CALLS THE WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT
ON THAT SPECIFICALLY. OUR WERE-
FIRST THING THEY SHOULD'VE DONE.
WAS YOU KNOW THE SAW THAT HE
WAS NOT VIOLENT THERE'S JUST NO
REASON HE WAS COMPLIANT SO
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THAT KIND
OF RESTRAINT THAT THE DEAD. AND
ALSO WITH THE MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH- I THINK IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BENEFICIAL FOR US TO SPEAK
ON THAT A LITTLE BIT SURE THE
MENTAL SORRY MISS BECOME A
LITTLE BIT- WHAT WE'RE
ADVOCATING FOR VERY ACTIVELY
RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS RESPONSE TEAMS I ONE WHO CALLED THE
POLICE AND I MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THAT I CHOSE THAT
BECAUSE IT FELT LIKE MY ONLY
OTHER OPTION WHEN- MY DAD WAS
TOO FAR AWAY- AND I. THERE ARE
VERY FEW THINGS I CAN
GUARANTEE- BUT I BELIEVE THAT
IF THERE HAD BEEN OTHER
OPTIONS- ESPECIALLY FOR HEALTH
CRISES I ABSOLUTELY WOULD HAVE
CALLED THEM. YOU ARE. I DID ASK
THEM MULTIPLE TIMES IF THERE
WAS SOMEBODY ELSE I COULD CALL
AND THEY SAID NO. YEAH SO. IT
WOULD OF. YEAH I'M SORRY. FOR
YOUR QUESTION YES THAT THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE. THOSE
WHO HAVE SUFFERED THE MOST B.
THE STRONGEST VOICE THE BIGGEST
ADVOCATES BECAUSE YOU YOU THAT
YOU WERE THERE YOU EXPERIENCED
IT. AND YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS YOU
FEEL COULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE HERE SO YOUR VOICE
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AB MRS.
COLUMNS YES. YOU MADE A COMMENT
THAT BROKE MY HEART YOU SAID
THAT THEY TRIED TO TELL YOU
THAT. YOU WERE PART OF THE
CAUSE. OF YOUR SON'S DEATH.
WHERE THE INLAND. ON THEIR
PRESS CONFERENCE IN- THE D. DAY
WERE DENYING IT THE THEY SAID
THERE WAS NO NEED TO THE NECK-
THE WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM YOU
KNOW THE ONES THAT HE SUSTAINED
THAT NIGHT WAS FROM THE
STRUGGLES WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHICH NEVER HAPPENED- NOTHING
LIKE THAT HAPPENED. IT AYE I
WANTED TO BRING ATTENTION TO IT
JUST TO REMIND YOU THAT YOU YOU
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT WITH
YOUR SON'S DEATH. AND I HOPE
YOU YOU DO YOU HAVE NOTE THAT
IT WHAT YOU DID IS EXACTLY WHAT
A MOTHER WHAT A FAMILY WOULD DO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BEST HLP YOUR YOUR SON AND IF
THERE IS NOTHING YOU DID THAT
WAS WRONG AND I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT. NOTHING YOU DID WAS
WRONG YOU CALLED EXACTLY WELL
YOU COULD HAVE CALLED FOR HELP
AT THAT MOMENT BECAUSE YOU WERE
TRYING TO HELP YOUR SON AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HEAR
THAT MESSAGE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE SOMETIME THANK YOU JUST
OH I'M SORRY YES SOMETIMES YOU
KNOW YOU I CAN'T LATE I TRIED
TO BLAME MYSELF FOR WHAT
HAPPENED- I KIND OF SAY YOU
KNOW IF I SHOULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING WHAT I MEAN. DID I DO
THE RIGHT THING I SHOULD OF YOU
KNOW SAID SOMETHING TO THEM
WHEN I SAW. THEM DOING THAT YOU
KNOW NEEDING. YEAH AND WE WILL
SEE. THE SAME THING WITH THE
GEORGE FLOYD TRIAL. WE ARE
SEEING THE YOUNG CLERK BLAME
HIMSELF FOR HAVING CALLED THE
POLICE. FOR THE COUNTERFEIT
DOLLAR- THAT HE FELT THAT THAT
THAT NOW ON IN RETROSPECT. BUT
EVERYBODY DOES THE BEST THAT
THEY CAN AT THAT MOMENT YOU DID
EXACTLY WHAT ANY PARENT WOULD
HAVE DONE. AND I AM SO SORRY SO
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I EIGHT EIGHT
QUESTIONS NOW MISTER CHIP
REPORT- TANYA FAISON. FOR S. I
HI I WANTED TO ASK IF YOU HAVE
NOTICED ANY CHANGES IN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND THE
COMMUNITY SINCE THE SUMMER OR
SENSE OF SINCE WE THERE THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH MORE AND THE
BEGINNING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE BUT I CHAIR GIPSON- I
HAVE NOT- I'VE SEEN. WHAT WHAT
AYE TENNESSEE LOCALLY IS- THE
POLICE CHIEF WILL MAKE
STATEMENTS THAT YOU KNOW.
APPEAR AS IF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IT IS GOING TO MOVE
DIFFERENTLY BUT WHEN YOU'RE IN
IN THE COMMUNITY- THOSE IT'S
THE SAME THING THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF HARASSMENT THERE'S STILL
A LOT OF THERE'S- I'M FROM OAK
PARK IN SACRAMENTO- AND IN THAT
COMMUNITY BY ITSELF. YOU'VE GOT
SACKED PT POLICING THAT
JURISDICTION'S ACTUAR US YOU'VE
GOT THAT MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW
POLICE UNIVERSITY PACIFIC
POLICE YOU GOT THE UC DAVIS
WHICH IS A HOSPITAL THERE
POLICE THEY LEAVE THE CAMPUS TO
THE POLICE THE COMMUNITY. AND
THEN YOU'VE GOT A SECURITY TEAM
THAT IS CONTRACTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THAT ONE
COMMUNITY IS POLICED BY ALL
THOSE DIFFERENT ENTITIES. AND
IT'S A HEAVILY GENTRIFIED
COMMUNITY AND SO YOU HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE CALLING THE POLICE ON
FOLKS THAT ARE NOW DISPLACED
AND HOMELESS OR YOU KNOW FROM
THAT COMMUNITY TRYING TO YOU
KNOW KEEP THEIR COMMUNITY HOW
IT USED TO LOOK BEING IN THE
PARK HANGING OUT. I'M NOT DOING
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING FOR YEARS
DECADES AND SO YOU'VE GOT A LOT
OF POLICE HARASSING
INDIVIDUALS- PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUALS DALY. SO WHEN I COP
WATCH I'LL SEE LIKE THIS ONE
PERSON THAT I KNOW WHO GETS
PULLED OVER NUMEROUS TIMES IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS AND SO THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M SEEING
EXPERIENCE. AND JUST. I PUT IT
IN AN- BECAUSE IT I HEARD
SOMEONE SAY THAT WE NEED TO
BUILD A BRIDGE AND I'VE HEARD
THAT TERM USED A LOT OF TIMES.
BUT I WANT PEOPLE TO LOOK AT
THE ABUSE THAT HAPPENS ON BROWN
AND BLACK COMMUNITIES. AS AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE WE'VE GOT A
WE'VE GOT DECADES OF AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP. AND THE ABUSE IS
THE BROWN AND BLACK PEOPLE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES AND THE
ABUSER IS THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. AND YOU'RE NEVER
GONNA TELL AN ABUSED PERSON TO
BUILD A BRIDGE WITH THEIR
ABUSER YOU'RE GOING TO TELL THE
USER TO GET WHAT THEY NEED TO
STOP DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING-
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
SEE. WE DON'T NEED TO SEE BROWN
BLACK PEOPLE DOING ANYTHING TO
MAKE SURE THAT PLEASE FEEL
COMFORTABLE AND HAPPY AND- AND
LIKE WE LIKE THEM AGAIN. WE
NEED TO SEE THE ABUSE STOP
HAPPENING SO I JUST WANTED AT
THAT. THANK YOU RIGHT I THINK
THAT THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
COMMENT AND I THINK THAT IF WE
TAKE THAT WITH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY'S COMMENTS- I THINK WHAT
WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE GOT TO MOVE
FORWARD. YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY HOUSE EXPERIENCE. THAT
THE REST OF US MAY NOT HAVE AND
WHEN YOU HAVE. GOOD COPS WE
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO ELEVATE THEM
SO THAT THE OTHERS DOWN KNOW
WHAT GOOD BEHAVIORS LIKE- AND
IN THAT REGARD AYE AYE I DO
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
FOR HIS YEARS OF SERVICE IN
THAT REGARD. AND THAT THAT'S
THE KIND OF BEHAVIOR COURTS NOT
AN ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP BUT YOU
ARE RIGHT IF IT IS AN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIP OFTENTIMES WE LOOK
TO THE VICTIM TO CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR RATHER THAN THE ABUSER
AND I AGREE WITH YOU THAT DOES
NEED TO STOP. BUT LET WILL FIND
WAYS TO USE BOTH COMMENTS TO
COME TO SOMETHING THAT'S GOING
TO BE FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY ARE
BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
THAT- BY BY ALL INDICATIONS BY
ALL STATISTICS ARE THE ONES
THAT SUFFER MOST IN THIS
REGARD. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENT AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE A FEW COMMENTS.
THE
RELATIONSHIP- OUR JOB IS TO
PASS LEGISLATION IT ISN'T IT TO
BE ON THE GROUND ALTHOUGH ALL
OF US I AND ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SPEND A LOT OF
TIME IN THE COMMUNITY. BUT WHAT
IS IT WE CAN DO IS LEGISLATORS
TO IMPROVE THIS RELATIONSHIP-
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY. I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO VIEW. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS A SYSTEM INSTEAD
OF AN INDIVIDUAL LIKE
INDIVIDUAL OFFICERS BECAUSE
IT'S A SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS FOR
OFFICERS WHETHER THEY'RE GOOD
OR BAD TO DO WHATEVER IT IS
THAT THEY'VE DONE AND SO THAT'S
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS AND THAT'S
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM- AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT LEGISLATORS
CAN DO IS TO HELP FIX RID OF
THE PROBLEM. ISSUES AYE WE SEE
A LOT OF BANDAIDS WE SEE A LOT
OF- YOU KNOW TEMPORARY FIXES OR
YOU KNOW GOOD STATEMENTS ARE
PERFORMATIVE GESTURES- BUT WE
NEED TO SEE ACTUAL ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM FIXES WHERE LAWS ARE
ACTUALLY BEING MADE THAT.
HONESTLY I FEEL LIKE. IF THERE
IS A PUNISHMENT IN PLACE FOR
OFFICERS THAT. HARM PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND I FEEL LIKE.
THAT THE HARM WILL STOP ITS
OFFICERS KNOW THAT THEY WILL.
BE FIRED AND POSSIBLY BE
INCARCERATED. FOR MURDERING
SOMEBODY THEN THAT WILL STOP.
IT'LL MAKE THEM THINK TWICE-
BEFORE DOING ANYTHING AND- IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT.
YOU KNOW ALL THESE OFFICERS ARE
GOING TO GO TO JAIL NOW LET'S
GET IT IT'S IT MEANS THAT
OFFICERS WILL NO LONGER JUMP
TO. RESORTING TO EXCESSIVE
FORCE OR VIOLENCE ON THE FIRST
RESPONSE SO I THINK IN
EVERYBODY'S LIFE WE ALL HAVE
JOBS THAT WE DO AND WE ALL HAVE
CHALLENGES ON OUR JOBS AND WE
HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS ON OUR
CHALLENGES AND WE ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT AM I GOING TO LOSE MY JOB
IF I MAKE THIS BAD DECISION.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I THINK THAT
OFFICERS NEED TO HAVE THE SAME
TYPE OF- YOU KNOW PROCESS RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE. YOU KNOW. FOR
EVER THEY'VE BEEN GETTING AWAY
WITH KILLING US SO. THAT IS THE
EXAMPLE THAT'S BEEN SET AND
THAT IS. I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
HURTING. OUR COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU AND THEY'LL TAKE TAKE THIS
MOMENT TARGET TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP- IN IN THE
SPACE YOUR YOUR VOICE HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOU MISTER CHAIR. CAN YOU HAVE
THEM. YOUR MOTHER CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW YES OKAY. WE'LL GET IT
TOGETHER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
GET IT TOGETHER- I WANT TO GO
TO A DOCTOR PORTER- PAST
REPORTER WITH RESPECT TO THIS
NEXT QUESTION- WHAT IS YOU FROM
YOUR LAND WHAT NEEDS TO TAKE
PLACE IN RELATION REGARDING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
MOVING FORWARD WHAT ARE SOME OF
YOUR SUGGESTIONS- BECAUSE YOU
SERVE AS THE STATE PRESIDENT OF
NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK- IN A
PASSED IN THE COMMUNITY IN
SACRAMENTO- AND FOR YOU
ACTIVISM WHAT CAN YOU SUGGEST
TO US. THAT CAN BETTER CREATE A
BETTER WORKING RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY. AND
POLICE AND POLICE AND THE
COMMUNITY. DOCTOR PORTER
CORRECT. YEAH THANK YOU ALL
WELL YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN- STATED
CLEARLY BEFORE THE TOP OF THE
TINY AND NOW- GOT OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HERE. I'LL
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK IS THE
KEY. WORD HERE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY- FOR
BAD ACTIONS I THINK IT'S JUST
THE SAMPLES THAT WE WANT ALL
FAIRNESS WANT JUSTICE- THAT
WOULD HELP TO RESTORE TRUST. ME
NO. BAD PEOPLE BROTHER THEY'RE-
POLICE OR OTHERWISE DO BAD
THINGS THEY SHOULD BE THEY
SHOULD BE HELD. ACCOUNTABLE
AND- HOW THE APPROPRIATE
CONSEQUENCES AND SO I THINK A
RESTORING OF FAIRNESS IN OUR
LAW MAKING- IS KEYS SO THAT
ABOUT BY DOING SO WE STORES ARE
CONFIDENCE AND TRUST. RETRAIN-
COMMUNITY LONG. WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN HEARING TRAIN TRAIN
TRY TRAINING ALL THESE YEARS
AND WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
PROGRESS WITH THAT SO THIS IS
NOT A TRAINING ISSUE THIS IS
WHAT I AM SAYING IS HOW PEOPLE
ARE PERCEIVED IT. IS OUR
CULTURAL IS SYSTEMIC AND WE
HAVE TO ATTACK IT IN THAT
MATTER WE CAN'T JUST ATTACK THE
SYMPTOMS WE HAVE TO ATTACK OF
THE WATCH CHIU WE ARE HIGHER IN
THESE. AS HELLO. OFFICIALS
WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES- J.
HIRE PEOPLE WHO ARE SCARED OF
THE CERTAIN CULTURES AND WE'RE
NOT BEEN EXPOSED WE'RE NOT
CLOSELY CROPPED COMPETENT. AND
ALL THAT AND SO WE- NEED TO WE
LOOK AT OUR HIRING PRACTICES
ADDED AGAIN. I GO BACK TO WORK
ON THE BILL THE IT DOES THE
FUTURE HEALTH STORE THE
CONFIDENCE OR ACTUALLY BRING
ABOUT CONFIDENCE AND TRUST IN
OUR MARKET MINISTRY. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY. OF TRAUMA- I
WANT TO GO TO THE DOCTOR- DR
PRICE SHARP WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR WORK YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
THE AREA OF TRAUMA CAN YOU
ELABORATE- FROM THE OFFICER'S
STANDPOINT AND ALSO ANY
VICTIMS. OR FAMILIES REGARDING
TRAUMA THAT YOU CAN- PROVIDES-
SOME TESTIMONIES AND ALSO
EXPERIENCE WITH. HELLO AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I
THINK THAT OFFICER MENTAL
HEALTH IS THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPORTANT FROM THE RESULT I'D
SAY THAT IS BECAUSE IF AN
OFFICER IS NOT MENTALLY HEALTHY
AND THAT CAN IMPACT. THE BILL
TO THEIR JOB AND TO OUR ACTS
WITH THE COMMUNITY. OBVIOUSLY
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH OUR
COMMUNITY IS ALSO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND PROVIDING A
BRIDGE FOR. PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT
POLLUTION THAT ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BRING HEALING TO
EVERYONE- I THINK- IS HAVE
EXTREME IMPORTANCE MANY
OFFICERS- YOU KNOW REALLY
STRUGGLE WITH. AND SO MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE OFFICERS GET
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED BECAUSE
THAT WAY THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
USE THAT PROPERTY OWNERS- AND
HAVING THEM MENTORED BY THOSE
GOOD OFFICERS THAT ARE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY EFFECTIVELY- AND- TO
BRING UITY TO THAT COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT MENTORING
PROCESSES GOOD MENTAL ALL CHECK
INS I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT I DO WELL LET'S CHECK
IN WITH A COUPLE OF DEPARTMENTS
AND I THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY HELP THE
COPS BECAUSE MENTALLY HEALTHY
COPS RESPOND. AN APPROPRIATE
WAY AND SO THAT I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO BRING HEALING TO
BALK BOB GOOD- BUT THERE ARE A
LOT OF OFFICE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH PTSD AND
DEPRESSION ON THEM. AND THAT
THAT ALSO GOING TO INFLUENCE
THEIR RESPONSES TO THE
COMMUNITY- I THINK THESE ARE
IMPORTANT TOPICS AND THE MORE
WE CAN BECOME UNIFIED AND THE-
I. ADDRESS THE ENTIRE PROBLEM
IT'S. GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
YOU ALSO MAY MINUTES OF THE
TRUCK THAT PLEASE OFFER HAVE A
BLOG THROUGH- AND I KNOW THAT
YOU I WORK FOR THE NUMBER OF
POLICE OFFICERS HAVE YOU AND I
PLEASE FORGIVE ME IF YOU'VE
ALREADY SAID THIS HAVE YOU.
EVER ADDRESS POLICE OFFICER
INVOLVED IN SHOOTING AND IF SO
HOW WAS THE OUTCOME IF YOU
COULD ELABORATE AND WHAT KIND
OF SERVICES THAT YOU PROVIDE.
AND THE REASON WHY FRAME THAT
QUESTION I'M SORRY THE REASON
WHY FRAME THAT QUESTION IS
BECAUSE- WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM.
THE KETO FAMILY AND OTHERS IS
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE- OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTING OR OFFICER
NEGATIVE CON CONTACT. ARE THERE
SOME TRAUMA THERE AND SO
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE TRY TO
ADDRESS THE TRAUMA. FROM THE
COMMUNITY STANDPOINT AS WELL AS
THE OFFICE'S STANDPOINT AND SO
THAT'S THE REASON WHY I POSED A
QUESTION- AS I AS I DID. SO OUT
OF YOU CAN PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO TRAUMA. OFFICERS AND
COMMUNITY AND VICTIMS.
ABSOLUTELY AND I HAVE MET WITH
MANY OFFICERS AFTER THEY HAVE
BEEN IN A SHOOTING AND I'VE
ALSO TREATED THEIR- OFFICERS
BUT SIGNIFICANT PTS. AFTER
THEY'VE DONE IN THIS YEAR ALONE
AND SO HELPING- THEM TO RE
CALIBRATE THEIR SYSTEM SET UP
AND TAKE THE NUMBER OF DAYS FOR
THAT OFFICER TO. COMPLETELY
COME DOWN FROM THAT MUCH OF
ADRENALINE AND THAT MUCH
CORTISOL THE NEEDS. AND FELL ON
AVERAGE IT TAKES ABOUT TEN DAYS
ACCORDING TO THE LETTERS CARE
SELL. OUT SOMETIMES DEPARTMENT-
MAYBE ARE NOT AS AWARE OF SOME
OF THOSE- RESEARCH FINDINGS
HIMSELF. HELPING OFFICERS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE A FEW DAYS TOP TO
BE ABLE TO RECALIBRATE SO
THEY'RE NOT GOING BACK IN THE
FIELD- YOU KNOW VERY- EXHAUSTED
AND NOT ABLE TO FUNCTION IN A
FULL CAPACITY I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND ALSO HELPING
THEM TO DEAL WITH THE DECISIONS
THAT THEY THEY MADE WHETHER
THEY WERE GOOD AND BAD
DECISIONS AT. THAT MOMENT- GO
AHEAD. OKAY NO CREDIT. OKAY SO
I THINK- HELPING DAMAGE- GOOD
TO BEGIN WITH WHICH IS THE-
MUTUALLY ARETHA OF TRYING- BUT
ALSO THEM TO COMPLY BECAUSE
BEST THEY GO ON- I WERE TALK
EXTENSIVELY TO OFFICERS AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE READY TO
RETURN TO FULL DUTY BECAUSE
RETURNING THEM- SOMETIMES SMALL
DEPARTMENT- THEY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY OF LETTING THEM
STAY OSCAR VERY LONG BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SUCH SHORT STAFFING-
SO I THINK THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE- AND ALSO
HAVING DEPARTMENTS UNDERSTAND
THAT AN OFFICER DOES NEED TIME
TO RECOVER. AND ALSO IF THERE
WAS A TRAINING ISSUE OR THEY
DID SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
CORRECT MAKES BUT THAT THEY
HAVE THE PROPER TRAINING AND.
SUPPORT BEFORE THEY RETURN. I
WANT TO THIS ASK ONE FOLLOW
PLACE IS THERE A- AFTER THE
OFFICE OF IN SHE- WHETHER
RESULTS IN ALLOW BEING. OR
DISCHARGING HIS OR HER FIRE ARM
BEFORE HERE. IS ALLOWED TO COME
BACK TO WORK IS THERE A TIME
BECAUSE YOU MAKE MENTION
SMALLER DEPARTMENTS THEY NEED
THAT OFFICER BACK SO THE TIME
MAY BE SHORTER BUT IS THERE A
STANDARD IN THIS IN IN THIS
SPACE. THAT REQUIRES X. AMOUNT
OF TIME FOR OFFICER TO- B.
BURKE- RETURNED BACK TO WORK
AND FOR WORK BEFORE HITTING THE
STREET IS THERE A TIME. THAT IS
SUFFICIENT. OR STANDARD. THAT
IS A VERY VERY GOOD AND VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION- NO THERE IS
NO STANDARD AND I HAVE ACTUALLY
KNOWN OFFICERS WHO WERE IN A
SHOOTING IN THE MORNING AND
ENDED UP GOING BACK TO WORK IN
THE AFTERNOON I KNOW ONE CASE
THAT HAPPENED- ABSOLUTELY GO
THE OPPOSITE WAS ACTUALLY SHOT-
AND THEN ALSO RETURNED FIRE AND
WAS BACK IN THE OFFICE IN THE
AFTERNOON WITH BANDAGES ON HIS
LEG AND BACK OUT ON PATROL YOU
KNOW SO I THINK THAT OFFICER
MENTAL HEALTH AND HAFIZ'S
PHYSICAL HEALTH IS. IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT BAD
BECAUSE THIS THIS IS A TRAGEDY
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED AND SO I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE SOME
THINGS TO LOOK AT THAT
OPPOSITION MENTAL HOAXES.
COMPONENT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THANK VERY MUCH- WHAT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- MISTER LUCKY YOU
HAVE NO QUESTIONS I HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE ONLINE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY- SO WE'LL MOVE ON WE
WANT TO THANK. YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE WANT TO MOVE TO
OUR NEXT PANEL INTO AGAIN
APPRECIATE. AGAIN DR PRICE
SHARP FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TANYA FAISON AND
ALSO- THE COLLINS FAMILY AS
WELL AS A DOCTOR PORTER FOR
YOUR COMMENTS WITH THERE MAY BE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SO WE ASK
YOU CAN STICK AROUND FOR AS
LONG AS YOU CAN. AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT- THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED HERE TODAY TO THE
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING. SO
WITH THAT. BEING SAID I WANT TO
MOVE TO- JULIA YOU I'M SURE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT.
IN P. A. P. A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY- SHE ACTUALLY MAY BE
JOINING US ON THE PHONE I
UNDERSTAND THERE WERE SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES- MISS
YOU ARE YOU WITH US. SIR I AM
HERE. THAT I TO. TURN ON THE
VIDEO. OKAY WE CAN WE CAN
REALLY REALLY WELL SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
AND THEN MOVE RIDE YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THERE GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JULIE YEAH HERO AND A CIVIL
RIGHTS. AND SENDING A GIRL
CALIFORNIA I SPENT ON THE BOARD
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY PROJECT
WHICH IS. THE LARGEST CIVIL
RIGHT ATTORNEY ORGANIZATION I
IN THE UNITED STATES WE HAVE
OVER SIX HUNDRED ATTORNEY
MEMBERS WHO SPECIALIZE IN
PLACEMENTS CONTACT WE HAVE OVER
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS SUPPORTERS FROM ACROSS
THE COUNTRY FROM ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES- IN ADDITION TO
TRAINING OUR ATTORNEY MEMBERS
AND P. EIGHTY PROVIDES OUR
EXPERTISE. TO STATE AND FEDERAL
LEGISLATORS ON POLICING REFORMS
MOST RECENTLY IN COLORADO- NEW
YORK AND NEW MEXICO WHERE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS BILL IS WAITING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE.
WE WORK WITH COMMUNITY GROUPS
TO FACILITATE DIALOGUE AMONG
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES- I THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS. HOW WE
AS A COUNTRY CAN HEAL
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TRAUMATIZING TIMES IN THE
MIDDLE OF DEREK SHOWBIZ
CRIMINAL TRIAL. I WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU WHAT WE MUST
DO IN OUR CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE GET TO A PLACE OF HEALING.
WELL FIRST COMMUNITIES RECOVER
FROM THE TIME. UNTIL THERE IS
PASSED TO JUST IN THE COURTS
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND
THE MENTAL VERSUS OF GOVERNANCE
IS THAT NO MAN IS ABOVE THE LAW
AND BOTH CHIANG AND POPPER MY
STATE HERE TO THE SAME SET OF
RULES. BUT QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
IN FEDERAL COURT AND ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
EXCELLENT PORTS THE ROLE WOULD
BE SPRINTS THE PULSE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IMMUNITIES DESTROY
COMMUNITY TRUST AND CREATE THE
PERCEPTION ACCESS STUNNED WHERE
POLICE MAKE JAIL BE MAIMED AND
LIE WITH IMPUNITY WHILE THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS STATE POLICE
ARE INCARCERATED AND VICTIMIZED
WITH NO RECOURSE AND PARKS THE
VINDICATE THEIR RIGHTS FOR
EVERY GEORGE FLOYD EVERY
BRIANNA TAYLOR THERE ARE
THOUSANDS THAT GET DOWN WHOSE
NAMES WE WILL NEVER HEAR SHE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DENIED JUSTICE.
IN A COUNTRY WHERE OUR
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLE EQUALITY
UNDER THE LAW OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ESPECIALLY OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE OF COLOR VIEW THAT THE
DO NOT. THEY DO THEY'RE NOT
BEING TREATED FAIRLY IMMUNITIES
EATING AWAY AT OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SEND A
CLEAR MESSAGE TO THAT EFFECT-
THAT. LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
ARE ALWAYS ABOVE THE LAW. AND
HERE IS WHAT IS AT THE HEART OF
THE PROBLEM IN FEDERAL COURT
WELL IN FIGHTING MANY PROTECTS
OFFICERS FROM LIABILITY EVEN IF
AN OFFICER IS FOUND TO HAVE
VIOLATED THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF SOMEONE. THE VICTIM
WILL STILL LOSE THAT CASE
UNLESS THEY CAN PROVE. THAT THE
PARTICULAR EXXON DOT WEISS
FOUND TO HAVE BEEN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN A PRIOR
CASE. WHAT I NEED BY THAT BY
SAMPLE THERE WAS A CASE CALLED
JESSOP IN CALIFORNIA A FEW
YEARS AGO THAT IS WHERE POLICE
OFFICERS CAME TO EXECUTE A
SEARCH WARRANT IN BASS STOLE
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF CASH
AND GOLD COINS. THE NINTH
CIRCUIT FOUND THAT THE OFFICER
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT STEALING
IS MORALLY WRONG. BUT BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO PRIOR CASE SAYING
THAT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL THE
PLAINTIFF IN THAT CASE THE
VICTIM STILL LOSES. AND WHAT IS
EVEN MORE PAINFUL IS THAT AT
THAT MOMENT THE NINTH CIRCUIT
DID NOT SAY AFFIRMATIVELY.
GOING FORWARD AS OF TO DATE
STEALING IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL SO
THE LAW IS STILL REMAINS THAT
AN OFFICER IS STILL TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND YOU CAN'T
SUE THEM FOR THAT BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T PROVE THAT. IT WAS
CLEARLY ESTABLISHED. I EVEN
WITHOUT QUALIFY IMMUNITY.
VICTIMS IN FOR IN FEDERAL COURT.
ONE OUT OF EVERY FOUR ACTIVE
FEDERAL JUDGES TO DATE IS A
TRUMP APPOINTEE. AND GIVEN THE
RHETORIC THAT HAS COME OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. VICTIMS OF POLICE
MISCONDUCT WELL ARE MOST OFTEN
BLACK OR BROWN. D. DEEP SENSE
OF MISTRUST BASED MISTRUST IS
UNDOUBTEDLY AND AMPLIFIED BY
THE DEADLY RIOTS AT THE CAPITOL
ON JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY
AS THE NATION WATCHED POLICE
OFFICERS ON WE ALLOW PARAKEETS
TO OPEN TO THE LAW LICENSE NOT
LESS MODERN. AND TAKES SELFIE
WITH THE MASTIC KERIS. THE
WORLD WHAT DONALD TRUMP
CONTRACT VIOLENCE IN NOTED THAT
DISTRICT TREATMENT OF THE
LARGELY WHITE WRITER AND THE
TREATMENT OF PROTESTERS. JOSH
THIS PAST SUMMER. LORD BE. SHOT
WITH PROJECTILE WEAPONS TEAR
GAS SOAKED IN CHEMICAL WEAPONS
CHANNELED AND SUBJECT TO MASS
FALSE ARREST FOR PEACEFULLY
CHANTING AND HOLDING SIGNS. WE
SAW THIS PLAY OUT ON TV IN
FRONT OF US. GIVEN THESE
PROBLEMS AND PUBLIC PERCEPTIONS
OF FAIRNESS IT ISCRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT VICTIMS OF
MISCONDUCT AND ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA STATE
COURT. WHERE THE BANE ACT
PROTECTS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS OF THE VICTIMS OF THIS
CONTACT. SIMILAR TO THE FEDERAL
LAW WHICH ALLOWS VICTIMS OF
GOVERNMENTAL AND BEAT YOU TO
SEEK JUSTICE IN FEDERAL COURT
THE BANE ACT ALLOWS
CALIFORNIANS TO SEEK JUSTICE IN
THEIR STATE PARKS. HOWEVER THE
BILLION ACTIVE ABSOLUTE
IMMUNITY TO OFFICERS WHO FRAME
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE PLANTING
EVIDENCE AND LYING UNDER OATH.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN A LOS ANGELES POLICE
OFFICER ACCIDENTALLY FILMED
HIMSELF PLACING A PACKAGE OF
PROTEIN IN A SUSPECT WHILE IT.
IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
LOS ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE REVEAL HER TOWARD- UP TO
TWENTY FIVE LAPD OFFICERS WERE
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR
FALSIFYING RECORDS ABOUT
ARRESTEES GANG AFFILIATIONS
WHICH ALLOWS PROSECUTORS TO
SEEK HARSHER SENTENCES AGAINST
DEFENDANTS. WHICH SOMETIMES
STATES INNOCENTLY. I THE
INTERNET. IN CALIFORNIA
OFFICERS MIGHT EVIDENCE BONTA
RECORDS AND LYING UNDER OATH
THANK YOU KNOW RELEVANCE THE
IMMUNITY IS ABSOLUTE AND IT
BECOMES MADE NOT RESTRICT
ACCESS FOR MALICIOUS
PROSECUTION. IT ENDED UP BEING
ACT IN CALIFORNIA. UNLIKE
FEDERAL COURTS CALIFORNIA DO
NOT ALLOW MEETING FAMILY
MEMBERS TO BRING A SUIT FOR
WRONGFUL DEATH ARE THE BANE ACT
THE COMMUNITY IS WELL AWARE OF
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT.
ONE OUT OF EVERY ONE THOUSAND
BLACK MALES EXPECT TO GET
KILLED BY THE POLICE IN NUYS
WANTED THAT STATISTICAL
ANALYSIS THAT HAS BEEN OUT
THERE IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
WE KNOW THAT ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN PEOPLE
WERE KILLED AT THE HANDS OF THE
POLICE. BLACK PEOPLE WERE
KILLED- 28% RATES OUT WHY DON'T
WE ONLY 13% OF THE ENTIRE
POPULATION. JUST. SENATOR
BRADFORD- I SPEECH TO
ADDRESSING DECERTIFICATION AND
AMENDING THE PAIN ACT WOULD
REMEDY THESE PROBLEMS AND ALLOW
THE COMMUNITY TO FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE A FAIR SHOT. IMMUNITIES
CREATES TOUGH ENVIRONMENT A
COMMUNITY DISTRUST IN WHICH WE
PUBLICLY OBSERVER THAT OFFICERS
ACT WITH EACH UNITY. I'M DOING
THE HARMS OF QUALIFIED AN
ABSOLUTE IMMUNITY IS ONE STEP
BUT THIS. CANNSTATT TOWARDS
TRANS TRUE TRANSFORMATION OF
THE SYSTEM OF RACIAL EQUALITY
IN ADDITION TO ERODING ANY
SENSE THAT EQUITY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IMMUNITIES ALSO HARM POLICE
OFFICERS THE MAJORITY OF WHO
ENTER THE PROFESSION WITH THE
TRUE SENSE OF PURPOSE TO SERVE
THE PUBLIC. IMMUNITY IS TAKE
AWAY THE PUBLIC TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE THAT IS CRITICAL FOR
OFFICER SAFETY AND EFFECTIVE
POLICING WHEN WE HAVE SUCH A BY
IN SUCH DISTRUST EVERY SINGLE
SINGLE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENCOUNTER IS SET UP FOR
FAILURE. WE MUST HAVE A
MECHANISM TO DECERTIFY LAB
WORKING OFFICERS SO THAT WE CAN
BRING HONOR BACK THE PROFESSION.
IT IS TIME TO BRING HONOR. AND
SRI. I OFFICIALS LIKE THE
PROFESSIONALS LICENSE FOR THAT
THEY ARE ENTITIES TIME TO HOLD
OUR POLICE OFFICER. ACCOUNTABLE
I IN LASTLY A LONG LONG ROAD TO
HEALING AWAITS THIS COUNTRY AND
THE COMMUNITIES HUNGER AND
DEMAND FOR MARKETS CREDIBILITY
WEISS DEMONSTRATED BY A NUMBER
OF LOCAL BALLOT MEASURES AND
INITIATIVES THAT PASSED IN
NOVEMBER ONE MINUTE MEETING AT.
YOUR ONE MINUTE. YES SETTING UP
NEW COMMUNITY CONTROLS AND
OVERSIGHT THIS IS WHY THE TIME
IS NOW TO CALIFORNIA BEING ACT
TO ELIMINATE IMMUNITIES AND
ALLOW VICTIMS OF DEADLY FORCE
TO BRING CLAIMS UNDER RUMPLED
ACT. SO THAT VICTIMS MAY SEEK
JUSTICE IN STATE COURTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY- NEXT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE- CHIEF
PRIDGEN. BOB DOLE PERCH AND HE
IS THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION C. P. C. A. AND
CHIEF OF THESE- SEASIDE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN SAN DIEGO HE WILL
PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY SO
CHEAP WHEN YOU ARE READY PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO CHIME IN AND SAY.
I'M GONNA USE A SELF AND THEN
PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR FOR BEING HERE. YES SO
GOOD MORE- CHAIR GIPSON THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION AND AS
MUCH AS I LOVE SAN DIEGO
ACTUALLY IN SEASIDE WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT TO A MORE BEAUTIFUL
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION. OF THE
BOOK MY NAME IS ABDUL PRIDGEN
I'M THE CHIEF OF POLICE OF THE
SEASIDE POLICE DEPARTMENT I AM
THE INCOMING PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. I'VE GOT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY YEARS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE.
TWENTY FIVE AND A HALF OF THAT
IS IN TEXAS AND ICE SKATE AFTER
TWENTY FIVE AND HALF YEARS AND
MADE MY WAY TO CALIFORNIA AND I
AM PRIVILEGED TO BE. HERE ONE
OF THE THINGS I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS WHAT CAN BE DONE. TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS OF TRUST
AND NOT JUST AFTER AN INCIDENT
AND I KNOW THAT'S THE FOCAL
POINT. BUT QUITE FRANKLY THESE
RELATIONSHIPS SHOULD EXIST
BEFORE SOME TRAGEDY OCCURS.
MORE SOME. INCIDENT OCCURS
THAT. SHAKES THE TRUST OF THE
COMMUNITY. IN ONE OF THINGS I
WANT TO REALLY. FOCUS ON OR
ADVISE THAT. IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE NEED TO BE HONEST ABOUT THE
ROLE WE'VE PLAYED IN THIS
COUNTRY AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND HOW HISTORICALLY WE
HAVE BEEN ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
HISTORY AND HOW WE HAVE USED.
OUR BAGGAGE AND THE LAW THE
DISADVANTAGE MANY PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THAT'S
CALLED RECONCILIATION AND IT'S
NOT SAYING THAT WE TODAY ARE
PROBLEMATIC IN ARE TROUBLESOME
AND ARE. LOOKING TO. ARM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT THAT
WE HAVE DONE IT IS STARKLY AND
CONTEMPORARILY IT HAPPENS IN
OTHER JURISDICTIONS EVEN IF NOT
OURS WHICH INFLUENCES THE WAY
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THEIR-
JURISDICTION SO I THINK WE NEED
TO BE HONEST ABOUT THAT NOT
TAKE IT PERSONALLY BECAUSE WE
ALL KNOW. THE ROLE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS PLAYED IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO.
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE THE
OTHER THING IS WE NEED TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND I'M PROUD TO
SAY THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION WAS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE WHICH ALLOWED FOR
THE RELEASE OF CERTAIN
INFORMATION WITH RESPECT TO
MISCONDUCT I KNOW THAT'S GOING
TO BE A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION.
THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT.
AND THEN ALSO SB TWO THIRTY
WHICH REQUIRES OFFICERS TO DE
ESCALATE SITUATIONS SO THEY
DON'T LEAD. TO SOMETHING TRAGIC
OR SOMETHING THAT I WILL COURSE
HOPE CAUSE HARM TO THE
COMMUNITY. DECERTIFICATION IS
ALSO TOP ON OUR LIST BECAUSE IF
PEOPLE. SHOULD NOT WEAR THE
BADGE IN YOUR DEPARTMENT I
SHOULDN'T WEAR IT IN ANY
DEPARTMENT IN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
CERTAINLY HIGH ON OUR LIST OF
THINGS WE LIKE TO COVERS. WHEN
IT COMES TO BUILDING TRUCKING
RELATIONSHIPS WE LOOK LIKE TO
LEAN ON THE PRESIDENT'S TASK
FORCE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
POLICING. WHERE AT THE VERY
FIRST BUILDING TRUST IN. WHICH
IS IT AND WHEN YOU DO THAT. IS
BY TREATING PEOPLE IN
PROCEDURALLY JUST WAYS THAT
MEANS YOU GIVE THEM A VOICE WE
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY
NOT BE JUDGMENTAL ARE YOU ALSO
NEED SHOWING YOUR DECISION
MAKING. YOUR TRUSTWOTHY AND
FINALLY YOU TREAT EVERYBODY
THAT YOU COME ACROSS NO MATTER
WHO THEY ARE WHERE THEY'RE FROM
WHO THEY KNOW WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT.
AND THEN YOU TRY TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE YOU CAN
ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY AND NOT
ENFORCEMENT SETS YOU'RE NOT
SHOWING UP ON A CALL FOR
SERVICE BUT YOU JUST OUTLINED
COMMUNITY WOULD YOU STOP THE
CAR AND GET OUT AND TALK TO A
BUSINESS OWNER. OR SOMEBODY IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD INTRODUCE
YOURSELF GET TO KNOW THEM AS A
HUMAN BEING. AND THAT TENDS TO.
YOU TEND TO TREAT THEM
DIFFERENTLY WHEN YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THEM IN
THE- BUT I JUST A PERSON IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT THAT'S MISTER
SMITH. HE'S GOT A SON WHO GOES
TO COLLEGE HE'S THE FOR FIRST
CHILD IN THAT PERSON'S FAMILY
TO GO TO COLLEGE. I THINK WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT ONE ANOTHER THE
MORE LIKELY LIKELY WE ARE TO
TREAT PEOPLE SKINNY ONE ANOTHER
IN. A HUMANE WAYS. AND THEN WE
HAVE TO. LOOK AT OURSELVES AS
COMMUNITY GUARDIANS AND NOT AS-
LAW ENFORCERS BUT LITERALLY
PEOPLE WHO SOLVE. COMMUNITY
ISSUES. AND WE DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE TO USE. THE LAW AS
LEVERAGE. TO TRY TO IMPROVE
SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY.
SOMETIMES IT'S- EVIDENCE OF
SOMEONE TO A RESOURCE. THAT
COULD GET THEM OUT OF THEIR
SITUATION WHETHER IT'S-
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER WHAT IT
MUST'VE VIOLENCE OR WHETHER
IT'S HOMELESSNESS. AND NOT
ALWAYS. LOOKING AT THE PENAL
SYSTEM. AS A WAY TO REMOVE. THE
WHAT WE MIGHT OR OTHERS MIGHT
PERCEIVE AS- PEOPLE WHO ARE.
COMMITTING CRIMES IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND I WOULD SAY THE
LAST THING IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. AND I KNOW
DOCTOR PORTER MENTIONED THIS IS
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU CAN SEND PEOPLE TO
TRAINING YOU CAN ADVISE THEM ON
HOW TO BEHAVE AND WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO. WHAT THEY NEED TO BE
CONSEQUENCES TO PEOPLE'S
ACTIONS IT IS NOT ALWAYS
CONSEQUENCES THAT YOU CAN SEE.
THINGS THAT RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF MEDIA ATTENTION THAT LEADS
TO A DEATH IT COULD BE JUST A
POLICY THAT WAS VIOLATED BUT
NOBODY WOULD KNOW ABOUT OTHER
THAN THE PEOPLE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT. AND SO THE CHIEF IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT PERSON WHEN
IT COMES TO HOW OFFICERS BEHAVE
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE PART.
BECAUSE OFFICERS NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ONE DAY WILL BE
REWARDED NAY WILL BE PRAISE
WHEN THEY DO WHAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH OUR MORES AND OUR
PRINCIPLES. BUT ALSO THEY WILL
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY
DO NOT. AND WHETHER THAT'S
SOMETHING SMALLER THAT
SOMETHING LARGE THEY WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND I THINK.
OUR ASSOCIATION IS MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION ONE MAKING SURE
THAT WERE MORE TRANSPARENT
BECAUSE I THINK THROUGH
TRANSPARENCY. ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL FOLLOW. AND ONCE THE
COMMUNITY SEES THAT WE CAN BE
TRUSTED BECAUSE WE'RE HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE. THEY'LL BE
MORE LIKELY TO WORK WITH US.
MORE LIKELY TO DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH US. AND MORE
LIKELY TO TELL US WHEN PEOPLE
COMMITTING CRIMES OF OAK WHICH
ULTIMATELY. MAKE THE COMMUNITY
SAFER BUT ALSO PEOPLE ARE LESS
FEARFUL OF THEIR INTERACTIONS
WITH THE POLICE BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE TO BE
GUARDIANS. AND NOT LAW
ENFORCERS. OR NOT WARRIORS. SO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME A
LITTLE TIME TO SHARE THAT WITH
YOU SURE GIPSON. CHIEF THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH AGAIN- THE
HE IS THE INCOMING PRESIDENT
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE. CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE WOULD JUST ASK IF
YOU CAN JUST STAND BY WE WILL
PROBABLY UNDOUBTEDLY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR YOU- IN A FEW
MOMENTS SO WITH THAT BEING SAID
I WOULD LIKE TO BRING UP. OUR
NEXT PANELIST MISS LINDA GILL
HILL- SHE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IT IS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD. CAL THE C.
B. WHO WILL BE PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY-
TO TALK TO MORE ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD OR COUNTY C. B. I STARTED
PROBABLY SHOULD BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN A YEAR AGO AS THE
INTRODUCTION OF OFFICER AND
THAT POSITION WAS MADE
PERMANENT IN MAY TWENTY TWENTY.
PRIOR TO THIS POSITION I WAS AT
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY FOR SEVEN YEARS WHERE WE
WORK TO CREATE MORE EFFICIENT
GOVERNMENT PROCESSES. AND
BEFORE THAT I WAS PRESS
SECRETARY FOR- DENTAL JOURNEY
GENERAL KAMEL HARRIS NOW VICE
PRESIDENT AND I WORK FOR TWO
STATE SENATORS I STARTED MY
CAREER AS A POLITICAL REPORTER
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE
BASED IN SACRAMENTO. IN MY TIME
HERE AT COPIES TO BE I'VE
LEARNED FIRST HAND THAT THE
VITAL WORK THAT WE DO AND
ASSISTING THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS
OF CRIME EACH YEAR TO HELP THEM
RECOVER. FROM THEIR TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES. IN THE- TWENTY
NINE TWENTY TWENTY CRYSTAL YEAR
COPIES TO BE PROVIDED A TOTAL
OF FIFTY EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN COMPENSATION
TO MORE THAN FIFTY THOUSAND
VICTIMS OF CRIME. OUR TASK IS
TO SERVE THOSE WHO ARE HURT BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ASSAULT.
HOMICIDE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
ROBBERY VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER%
AND ONE OTHER CRIMES. VICTIMS
OF CYBER PHYSICAL INJURIES
DIRECT PHYSICAL INJURIES OR
EMOTIONAL INJURY AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THESE CRIMES. YOU MAY
QUALIFY FOR ASSISTANCE.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU'RE HOW B. C.
B. PROVIDES UP TO SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT OF EXPENSES AS
THE PAIR OF LAST RESORT TO
COVER COSTS CREATED BY CRIMES
SUCH AS MEDICAL AND DENTAL
CARE. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
INCOME LOST FUNERAL EXPENSES
RELOCATION COSTS AND
RESIDENTIAL SECURITY. IN THE
PAYER OF LAST RESORT MEANS A
COPY CP ONLY PAYS EXPENSES
AFTER OTHER AVAILABLE FUNDS
SOURCES OF PAYMENT HAVE BEEN
IT'S AUSTIN. THESE SERVICES
INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT LIMITED TO
HEALTH INSURANCE WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSURANCE AUTO
INSURANCE MEDI CAL MEDICARE.
FOR COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
QUALIFYING CRIME BUT THAT ARE
NOT COVERED BY OTHER SOURCES OF
PAYMENT HOW DO YOU SEE BEING IT
PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT OF
BILLS. WE DEPARTMENT OF ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY STAFF AND THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE INVOLVED
IN PROCESSING PLANTS
APPERCEPTION APPLICATIONS
DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY AND
PAYING BILLS. OBVIOUSLY BE ALSO
COMPENSATES PEOPLE BEEN
WRONGFULLY CONVICTED OF A CRIME
AND SPENT TIME IN PRISON WE
PROVIDE GRANTS TO TRAUMA
RECOVERY CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO HELP VICTIMS OF CRIME.
AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT VICTIMS
OF MASS VIOLENCE EVENTS SUCH AS
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING OR THAT
YOUR DAUGHTER TESTABLE. OUR
GOAL IS TO HELP VICTIMS OF
CRIME BEGIN TO RECOVER FROM THE
TRAUMA THEY'VE ENDURED IT
WHICHEVER VICTIMS AND ALSO WHAT
WE CALL DRIVEN TO VICTIMS.
THOSE ARE SURVIVORS OF CRIME
VICTIMS WHO HAVE DIED- PERSONS
OR LARGE LEGALLY DEPENDENT ON
THE VICTIM OF THE CRIME FOR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. AND MEMBERS
OF THE VICTIMS FAMILY THAT
COULD INCLUDE PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS SIBLINGS CHILDREN
SPOUSES GRANDCHILDREN OF THE
VICTIM. TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE YOURS AND-
IT'S ONE LAST FISCAL YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT TOP THREE TYPES OF
CRIMES THAT WE RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS FOR WERE ASSAULT
WITH THE AVERAGE JUST OVER
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. CHILD ABUSE
NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS AND HOMICIDE OVER
FIVE THOUSAND APPLICATIONS. AND
THE TOP THREE EXPENSES THAT WE
COVERED INCLUDE MENTAL HEALTH
WHERE WE PAID NEARLY EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. FUNERAL AND
BURIAL COSTS MORE THAN ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND INCOME
SUPPORT WAS WAS ALSO JUST OVER
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. MUCH
MORE DETAIL ABOUT OUR PROGRAM
AND ALSO SUGGESTED SURVIVAL ON
OUR WEBSITE. B. C. B. IS FUNDED
THROUGH RESTITUTION FINES AND
PENALTY ASSESSMENTS LEVIED ON
PERSONS CONVICTED OF CRIMES OR
TRAFFIC OFFENSES RESTITUTION
ORDERS THE STATE COUNTY FONG
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS AND THE
STATE GENERAL FUND. BECAUSE A
RESTITUTION FUND HAS DECLINED
IN RECENT YEARS WE HAVE
RECEIVED INCREASING SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE GENERAL FUND THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PROPOSES A
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BACK FEEL TO THE
RESTITUTION FUND AN ONGOING
THIRTY NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. THEREAFTER COUNTY C.
B. CALIFORNIA HAS A PROUD
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING ITS
VICTIMS IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT THE NATION'S
FIRST VICTIM COMPENSATION
PROGRAM WHICH IS TODAY COUNTY
CV. ALL FIFTY STATES THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA IN MANY
TERRITORIES ALSO CURRENTLY
HOBBIT AND COMPENSATION
PROGRAMS MANY MODELED AFTER
WHAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. OUR PROGRAM IS
THE MOST ROBUST IN THE COUNTRY
IN TERMS OF SERVICES PROVIDED
TO VICTIMS AND THE MOST MOST
COMPLEX INSURANCE OF ITS
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
OBVIOUSLY HE WORKS CONTINUOUSLY
TO EXPAND ITS OUTRAGE BY
NETWORKING WITH DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE'S VICTIM
SERVICE PROVIDERS AN AVERAGE
IT'S TELLING SOCIAL WORKERS
COURT OFFICIALS AMONG OTHERS.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON HELPING
VICTIMS OF CRIME RECOVER FROM
THE PAIN AND INJURIES CAUSED BY
BUT I WENT CRIME. I TELL B. C.
B. WE'RE DRIVEN BY IT'S
IMPORTANT AND MEANINGFUL
MISSION THE EACH YEAR HELPS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OVERCOME TRAUMATIC
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES. THANK YOU
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR- IF WE GET
YOU JUST STAND BY WE'LL HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL- AS
WELL AS MYSELF. AND WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR OUR NEXT SPEAKER-
WE HAVE DOCTOR BANQUETTE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR OAKLAND
YOU. ARE JOINING US WILL BE
WITH US AND PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY- DR A BANK HEAD ARE
YOU WITH THIS. I AM HERE I'M
TRYING TO START THE VIDEO. WERE
BANNED TASTIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US IF YOU CAN
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
THEN BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION WE
WELCOME YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT
WELCOME I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE
HERE IT'S AN HONOR- AND I'M
THERE YEAH ALL RIGHT. SO MY
NAME'S TIANJIN BANKHEAD AND I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR OAKLAND
YOUTH- IT'S A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
NONPROFIT THAT'S LARGELY
CREDITED. WITH RATIONS WITH
KIND OF INFUSING RACIAL JUSTICE
DIALOGUE INTO THE MODERN
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE MOVEMENT-
I'M ALSO A BOARD MEMBER. OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF. ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY NEAR TO
MY- EXPERIENCE. AND IT'S THAT
ISSUE OF HEALING LIKE TRUE AND
DEEP FEELING- AFTER POLICE
MISCONDUCT. SO POLICE OFFICERS
AS HAS BEEN SAID EARLIER I'M
NOT ABOVE THE LAW AND SO WHEN
THEY ENGAGE IN HARM. THEY'RE
OFTEN RACIALLY BIASED
IRRESPONSIBLE AND AN
UNSUBSTANTIATED VIOLENCE IS A
BOLD VIOLATION OF A UNIQUELY
SACRED TRUST. THAT'S ALREADY
BROKEN AND BACKPACK COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE OF HISTORICALLY ROOMS.
SO THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE
HOW DO COMMUNITIES REPAIR FROM
POLICE TRAUMA WHETHER THE
MISCONDUCT TAKES THE FORM OF
LETHAL FORCE ABUSE OF POWER
OVER POLICING OR UNCONSCIOUS
RACIAL BIAS HOW TO COMMUNITIES
TRULY HE L. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
OFFERS A MODEL FOR RESPONDING
TO RUN DOING WHERE THE PAIN OF
THESE HARMS RUNS DEEP. DIVIDING
PEOPLE AND FRACTURING
RELATIONSHIPS. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE OFFERS A RADICALLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH IT ASKING
QUESTIONS LIKE WHICH
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE BEEN BROKEN
AND WHAT DOES THE COMMUNITY
AGREE COULD BE DONE TO HEAL. IT
IS THOROUGHLY INCLUSIVE
COMMUNITY DRIVEN AND GRASSROOTS
IN ITS ORIENTATION. FOR EXAMPLE
LET'S IMAGINE A SITUATION OF
POLICE RUN GENERATE WHERE
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD UNARMED BLACK
BOY IS SHOT BY A POLICE OFFICER
OFFICER WHO SAID HE THOUGHT THE
STUDENTS PENCIL CASE WAS A GUN.
FOR EXAMPLE SAKE LET'S IMAGINE
THAT THE TEENAGE PERSON LET.
THE COMMUNITY THE FAMILY AND
THE BOY WOULD LIKELY FEEL MANY
THINGS DEVALUED HOW ARE LISTS.
AND DEHUMANIZED THEY ALSO FEEL
HATRED RESENTMENT VENGEANCE
RETRIBUTION RACIALLY TARGETED
IN BETRAYED. AND THE POLICE
OFFICER MIGHT FEEL ANGER.
RESENTMENT FEAR SHE AND SELF
RIGHTEOUSNESS. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE WOULD HAVE AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO RESOLVING
THIS CONFLICT THEN I CURRENT
RETRIBUTIVE SYSTEM. IN
ATTEMPTING REPAIR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE WOULD SINCERELY EXPLORE
HOW WE FIRST IDENTIFY THE
VICTIMS AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN HARMED. HEY WE
WOULD CONSIDER BOTH THE
INDIVIDUALS MOST IMPACTED BY
THE HARM AND THE COMMUNITY
EXPERIENCING HARM. FOR
DIFFERENT ALTHOUGH INTEGRATED
RESPONSES. SO A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE CIRCLE MIGHT ORGANIZED
WITH PEOPLE MOST INTIMATELY
IMPACTED BY THE HARM AND THAT'S
CAUSING. SO THIS WOULD INVOLVE
BRINGING TOGETHER THE POLICE
OFFICER AND THE PERSON HARMED
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
OTHERS MUST INTIMATELY IMPACTED
FOR HARM CIRCLE. AFTER
SIGNIFICANT CIRCLE PREPARATION
DURING THE HARM CIRCLE ALSERKAL
MEMBERS WOULD ADDRESS KEY
QUESTIONS AND BE ENCOURAGED TO
FULLY AND DEEPLY AND
AUTHENTICALLY SPEAK THEIR
TRUTH. THEY WOULD TELL EACH
OTHER THEIR STORY OF WHAT
HAPPENED WHAT RELATIONSHIPS
WERE BROKEN AS A RESULT OF THE
HARMFUL ACTION AND THEY WOULD
WORK TOGETHER TO DETERMINE BY
CONSENSUS WHAT WAS NEEDED TO
HELP THE HARM. THE OFFENDER
POLICE OFFICER WOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HARM
THAT COST. THEY WOULD ATTEMPT
TO MAKE AMENDS APOLOGIZE AND
PROFOUNDLY COMMUNICATE A
COMMITMENT TO THE BEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE TO REPAIRING THE HARM.
THEIR RESTITUTION REPARATIONS
AND OTHER YET UNKNOWN CREATED
MEANS THAT THE GROUP COULD COME
TO TERMS WITH. RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE IN THE SPACES IS A
PROFOUNDLY MOVING AND
TRANSFORMATIVE PROVOCATIVE AND
SOLUTION FOCUSED PROCESS IT CAN
BE REALLY LIFE CHANGING FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS. BOTH FOR THOSE
WHO CAUSED THE HARM AND FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED AS
IT HUMANIZES EVERYBODY IMPACTED
BY THE HARM. CIRCLE MEMBERS ARE
NOT SUSPECTS AND OFFICERS BUT
HUMAN NEEDS PEOPLE. IN THE
PROCESS PUTS THEM ALL UP CLOSE
AND PERSONAL. THERE IS NO
HIDING BEHIND A SHIELD A BAD OR
BRAVADO. IT CAN BE A VULNERABLE
HE LIED AND I OFTEN TAKE SPACE
TO ENTER INTOTHAT BRINGS US
ALL CLOSER TO OUR SHARED
HUMANITY AS WE SET WITH. LOOK
AT AND LISTEN TO THE PAIN
CAUSED AND FELT BY EACH OTHER.
IT ALSO CREATES AN OPENING FOR
EXPRESSIONS OF REMORSE
AUTHENTICITY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
FORGIVENESS. CURRENTLY HOWEVER
THEIR BARRIERS FOR POLICE
OFFICERS WHO WANT TO ENGAGE IN
THIS PROFOUNDLY
TRANSFORMATIONAL PROCESS.
BECAUSE THE POLICING SYSTEM IS
INVESTED IN PROTECTING ITSELF
THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
LAWSUITS AND COVER UPS IN
PUNITIVE CULTURE SO MUCH SO
THAT POLICE OFFICERS WHO ONE
EKG THESE RESTORATIVE PROCESS
SEES ARE DISCOURAGED OR
PREVENTED FROM DOING SO BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS. WELL ACTUALLY
DI<c.cyan> IT'S OFTEN BY SARAH GET</c>
OFFICERS OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC
HI BECAUSE SOME OF THAT THE
OFFICERS THEMSELVES RECOGNIZE
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY IS THEIR
ONLY TRUE PATH. TO THEIR OWN
FREEDOM AFTER CROSSING. SO FAR
THE SCALE COMMUNITY HEALING AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE COMMUNITY
HEALING RESPONSE TO POLICE
MISCONDUCT CAN BE ORGANIZED IN
A SERIES OF COMMUNITY BUILDING
CIRCLES FOLLOWING HARM. THIS IS
WHERE OFTEN GRASSROOTS GROUPS
OR INDIVIDUALS ORGANIZE TALKING
SPACES HEALING SPACES AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PLACES UP
FOLLOWING WHAT POLICE HARM IT
HAS WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY
IMPACT. IN OAKLAND WHERE OP IS
CALLS ON RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
LEADERS TO ORGANIZE THESE
HEALING TALKING SPACES AFTER A
POLICE KILLING OF AN ARMED.
PERSON IN ANTICIPATION. OF
COMMUNITY. SOME SORT OF TAX
OFFICER OFFICE OF. TO COMMUNITY
HEALING AFTER BECAUSE BY POLICE
BUT NOT REPLACING HARM FOR
ANOTHER HARM BUT BUYING HONEST
APPROACH TO HEALING THE HARM IN
OUR COURTS JUSTICE. BUT MY
EXPERIENCE WITH IMPACTED
FAMILIES THEY NEED THREE THINGS
ACCOUNTABILITY WHICH HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT THIS MORNING
ALREADY A LOT TRANSPARENCY AND
A RADICAL CHANGE AND POLICE
CULTURE. SO IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY PUBLIC FAMILIES
JUST WANTED POLICE TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT THEY'VE
DONE TO NAME IT AND TO CLAIM.
SAID THAT SHE MOVEMENT TOWARDS
WHOLENESS THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY BY POLICE
INSTITUTIONS BOTH INDIVIDUAL
OFFICERS AND POLICE AUTHORITIES
NEED TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY A
WRONGFUL ACTION. ON THE
PROBLEMS THE PROBLEMS OF POLICE
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS AND STOP
BLAMING THE FAMILIES AND
VICTIMS THAT ARE MOST HARMED.
HE STARTED CAN YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. OKAY VIRTUALLY TO
HAPPEN IMPACT PEOPLE. THEY NEED
TO SEE TRANS. I'M SIX AND THEY
WANT THE CANDIDATES AROUND
ELEVEN OF IMPLICIT BY. IN
FAMILIES ALSO WANT TRANSPARENCY
TRANSPARENCY IN POLICE
DEPARTMENTS IN THOSE STRUCTURES
AROUND HIM FORM SYSTEMS THAT
SEEKS IMPENETRABLE BY OUTSIDERS.
AND THEY WANT A RADICAL CHANGE
IN REFORM TO POLICE AFTER
POLICE HEALTHCARE IS SEEN TO BE
ROPED- AND- PEOPLE IMPACTED ONE
THESE KIDS TO END THEIR CODE OF
SILENCE THAT SEEMS TO ONLY
PROTECT FINANCIAL INTERESTS AND
THE OLD BOYS NETWORK. SO LASTLY
I GUESS I'LL SAY THAT THERE IS
A DIRE NEED FOR THIS UPSTREAM
RADICAL POLICE CULTURE REFORM.
SOME MIGHT SAY THE BEDROCK OF
POLICING IN THE UNITED STATES
IS ROOTED AND ABUSE OF POWER
AND FLAGRANT DISREGARD FOR THE%
VALUE OF HUMAN LIVES THAT
RESIDE IN BLACK AND BROWN
BODIES AND THE BODIES OF OTHER
UNDER REPRESENTED PERSONS. I'M
HAS TRULY. FOR US TO REVAMP OUR
POLICE INSTITUTIONAL PRACTICES
TO EMBRACE AN AUTHENTICALLY
HEALING JUSTICE WHERE
ACCOUNTABILITY FAIRNESS AND
DIGNITY RULE AND WHERE THE
VOICE OF HUMANITY OF EVERY
HUMAN BEING IS VALUED. THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- DOCTOR BANKER WE
APPRECIATE YOU IF YOU COULD
JUST STAND BY WE WANT TO- WILL
BE GOING TO SOME QUESTIONS- IN
A FEW MOMENTS SIX. OKAY THE
FIRST QUESTION- I'M GOING TO
ASK- THIS- BECAUSE LINDA- WHAT
CRIED WHAT CRIMES ARE COVERED
BY THE COW- THE- AND HOW HAS
THEY CHANGED OVER THE TIMES
OVER TIME. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR- WHEN
CALVIN CLV WAS ESTABLISHED IN
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
PROGRAM ONLY COVER DRUG VICTIMS
OF VIOLENT CRIME THE CAUSE
PHYSICAL INJURY AND SO PHYSICAL
ASSAULTS AND HOMICIDES AND WERE
WHAT WE WERE COVERED- BUT OVER
THE PAST FIFTY SIX YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXPANDED THE
QUALIFYING CRIMES THAT ARE
COVERED BY KELSEY VCP- AND
ESPECIALLY IN THE EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES THIS WAS EXPANDED TO
INCLUDE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL ASSAULT. VEHICULAR
CRIMES- AND THE MOST RECENT
ADDITIONS INCLUDE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING STOCKING AND
DISTRIBUTION OF CHILD **** SO-
AMONG THE CRIMES WE COMMIT-
COVERS ALL CHILD ABUSE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DRUG DRIVING AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ONLINE HARASSMENT
ROBBERY A CENTRAL ASSAULT AND
STALKING. TERRORISM AND YOU
CATCH WHAT MANSLAUGHTER ALL
CRIMES AND THAT HOW DOES JUST
OR INJURY OR THREAT OF PHYSICAL
INJURY OR IN SOME CASES- SUCH
AS ONLINE HARASSMENT WHICH
MENTAL HARM THAT HAS BEEN
CAUSED. BY THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF UP FOR YOU- HOW DO
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME APPLY-
AND HOW TO GET COMPENSATION FOR
MY ORGANIZATION CAN YOU WALK US
THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- THAT DEMONSTRATE
APPLY DIRECTLY ONLINE AT CHAO
B. C. B. OR THROUGH A PAPER
APPLICATION- BUT MANY ALSO.
HELPED IT THROUGH- I DID JUST
WITNESS AT ASSISTANCE CENTER
LISTED LOCATED IN MANY COUNTIES
AND MANY PARTICIPATE AND ARE IN
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS OFFICES ON
MANY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THOSE
ASSISTING- SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AND CAN HELP VICTIMS-
WITH- I'M FILLING OUT AN
APPLICATION WE ALSO PROVIDE-
ARE BENT OUT RECHARGE TO BLOCK
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
THEY CAN ALSO CANDID THAT JOBS
TO HELP THEM RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO APPLY.
AND WE HAVE AN ONLINE RESOURCES
AND ONE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER
THE VICTIMS ARE ABLE TO COLLEGE
RECEIVED HELP. WHEN THEY SUBMIT
AN APPLICATION- NECESSARY
DOCUMENTATION INCLUDING OUR
PRIME REPORT ON STUFF VERIFIES
THE INFORMATION- AND THEY TRY
TO GATHER ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO VERIFY THE
CRIME- AND THEN ONCE THE
APPLICATION IS APPROVED- THEN
WE WOULD START RECEIVING BILLS
AND REMEMBERED START
REIMBURSING FOR BELTS- WE-
AVERAGE ABOUT SAID. FIVE DAYS-
FOR APPROVING AT APPLET IN THE
FISCAL YEAR- WE- MAKE PAYMENTS
DIRECTLY TO- THAT SO EITHER
YOU'RE A MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
OR A PHYSICIAN OR HOSPITAL OR
FUNERAL BURIAL. HOME AND WE
WE'VE HELP WE PROVIDE THAT-
PAYMENT DIRECTLY TO THE
PROVIDERS- SO THE VICTIMS-
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THOSE
COSTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
POLOKWANE FOLLOW QUESTION-
VICTIMS OF POLICE MISCONDUCT
ARE THEY INCLUDED AS WELL.
THERE'S CURRENT IF- IF THERE'S
A CRIME REPORT AND THAT'S FINE-
THE VERIFICATION OF A CRIME
THAT'S OCCURRED- THEY WOULD BE
INCLUDED UNDER CURRENT STATUTES
SO THERE'S ALSO PENDING
LEGISLATION- ON THAT MATTER
RIGHT NOW IN THE LEGISLATURE SO
I'LL- DEFER TO. THAT POLICY
PROCESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CHIEF ARE YOU STILL WITH US I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR IT FOR YOU.
FROM A POLICE OFFICER- YEAH
FROM A POLICE OFFICER OR HIS OR
HER DEPARTMENT STANDPOINT. WHAT
ARE THE METHODS WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT USED TO REPAIR.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY AFTER. THEY COMMIT-
SOME MISCONDUCT- HOW IMPORTANT
IS IT. THAT THE OFFICER OF
THEIR OF THAT TO THAT
DEPARTMENT- MEMORY PHRASE THAT.
WINOGRAD OFFICER IS ACCUSED OF
MISCONDUCT HOW IS THE DATA
DRASTIC NâNG WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO IN THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION MISTER CHAIR I
THINK. IT'S SO VITALLY
IMPORTANT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT DEPARTMENTS ONE
OPERA OPERATING PROCEDURE WE
JUST LEASE AND THAT IS. GIVING
A VOICE TO THE COMMUNITY SO
PART OF THAT IS LISTENING TO
THE COMMUNITY'S CONCERNS AND
BEING RESPONSIVE. AND LISTENING
ACTIVELY ABOUT WHAT THE
COMMUNITY BELIEVES NEED THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WILL IMPORT TO
PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE THAT
FROM OCCURRING. NOW THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA UNLESS SOMETHING
BECOMES. PUBLIC FODDER FOR
EXAMPLE IF IT MAKES IT INTO THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN. INFORMATION
CANNOT BE RELEASED ON
INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE HOPE TO CHANGE
MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE AGAIN
THAT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. SORT
OF INHIBITS OUR ABILITY. TO
SHOW THAT WE ARE HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND TO BUILD TRUST.
SO RIGHT NOW UNLESS IT'S IN THE
YEAR THE ONLY THING WE CAN DO
IS COMMUNICATE WITH THE PERSON
WHO LIVES THE COMPLAINT TO GIVE
THEM THE RESULTS OF THE
COMPLAINT. WELL LET'S SAY
SOMETHING DID GO PUBLIC I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE AGENCY
TO BE IN A COMMUNITY TALKING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED BEING
HONEST AND FORTHRIGHT AND IF WE
MAKE MISTAKES. LET'S OWN UP TO
WHAT I KNOW I HEARD THAT THE
DOCTOR MENTIONED THE CONCERNED
ABOUT LAWSUITS AND THERE ARE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONCERNED WITH
THAT BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT IS
BUILDING TRUST. AND NOT
NECESSARILY SAVING A COUPLE OF
DOLLARS ON THE BACK IN. THE
COMMUNITIES CONSTRUCTIVE SO I
BELIEVE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS TO BE TRANSPARENT. AND
TO BE ACCOUNTABLE AND TO LISTEN
ACTIVELY TO WHAT THE COMMUNITY
IS SAYING AND RESPOND TO THOSE
REQUESTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHIEF OF FOR RESPONDING TO THAT
QUESTION. WANT TO GO TO MISS-
BANQUETTE- WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
DO YOU THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE DOING- TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS WHOLE
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE KIND OF. OF
SPACE. CAN YOU NAME A THREE
POINTS THAT YOU LIKE TO. SHARE
WITH US. THAT YOU THINK THROUGH
YOUR WORK OBJECT IT WILL BE
VERY USEFUL FOR US TO CONSIDER.
AS WE DO THIS WORK IN TERMS OF
REFORMING A REIMAGINE WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPECTING IN THIS
STATE. YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION- THE BIG QUESTION I
WOULD SAY NUMBER ONE AND A
FOCUS ON RESTORATIVE POLICING
THERE ARE SOME EXAMPLES
WORLDWIDE IN THE CITY OF HULL
ENGLAND FOR EXAMPLE IT'S A
RESTORATIVE CITY IT USES
RESTORATIVE APPROACHES IN
POLICING SO NOT. IS TO INFUSE
THESE PRACTICES AND PRINCIPLES
BUT TO REALLY MAKE ORGANIZED
THE SYSTEMS THEMSELVES- TO
FOCUS MORE ON RELATIONSHIPS AND
DIALOGUE AND RESOLVING
WRONGDOING NOT ONLY FOCUSED ON
CRIME SO THERE'S A THERE'S A
COMPLETE KIND OF RE ORIENTATION
IN POLICING AND I WOULD ARGUE
FOR- AND I THINK MOST
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PRACTITIONERS WOULD TOO SO
THAT'S A BIG THING WHICH DEALS
WITH- THAT KIND OF%
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN OUR
POLICE SEEMED KIND OF SYSTEMS
THEMSELVES. YES AND THAT'S ONE
AND IT'S A NUMBER TWO- WOULD BE
TO SINCE TWO I AGREE WITH
WHAT'S BEEN SAID ABOUT TRAINING
LIKE YOU CAN'T TRAIN RACISM OUT
OF PEOPLE BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
GIVE- POLICE OFFICER IS A KIND
OF AN ORIENTATION THAT SPEAKS
TO THE HEART OF THAT IMPLICIT
BIAS DOESN'T HAPPEN SO THAT IT
IS ELIMINATED IN A DEEP WAY AND
SO FOR THAT TO HAPPEN YOU CAN'T
JUST TEACH PEOPLE AND TRY TO
SPEAK TO THE HEAD AND TRY TO
INTELLECTUALLY. GET THEM TO NOT
WE HAVE A REFLEX THAT IS NOT
LARGELY UNCONSCIOUS IN IN A
MOMENT WHERE HARM OCCURS SO
IT'S MORE THAN JUST TRADING IT
IS. AN EXPERIENCE REALLY THAT
IS RESTRUCTURING A LIFETIME OF
YOU KNOW TAKING AND A WHITE
SUPREMACIST KIND OF A CULTURE
AND ENVIRONMENT SO JUST BEING
REALLY. SERIOUS AND SINCERE
ABOUT. I DON'T WANT THE TREE
BUT UP ABOUT RE. THE OF THE
CALL- POLICING BASICALLY BOTH
HOW POLICE UP. ENGAGE THOSE
ACTIVITIES HOW THIS HOW THE
THAT IT POLICE INSTITUTIONS-
OUR BRAVE. MEN IT'S- AN ORGAN
AND THEN WHAT THEIR
EXPECTATIONS ARE OF THEM. YES I
RACES- YOU KNOW KIND OF EITHER
AND APPROACH SO I WOULD SAY
THOSE TWO THINGS IN THE LAST
JUST OPENING UP THE WAYS IN
WHICH- IS OFTEN. THIRD AND A
COMMUNITY CAN'T INTERACT SO
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS
NEW DEEP INTO HEALING SO YES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HARM TO
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN HARMED
THAT HAVE BEEN HARMED WANT-
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WHAT'S THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY LOOKS LIKE IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT AN
OVERSIGHT BOARD. ART I TELL YOU
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS TO OUR ARMED AND
COMMUNITIES. AND KIND OF. IN
TERMS OF THE POLICE. RESPECT
AND THE- AND THE COMMUNITY
NETWORK DINNER ALSO. CONSENT
EXISTENCE IS DONE THE- FOR THAT.
BUT TO KIND OF GO OVER THE
OUTSIDE THIS IS BUT THAT'S HOW
TO COMPLETE ACT HAPPY SO MANY
OF THESE OTHER RESPONSE ARE YOU
KNOW BAND ON A GUNSHOT WOUND
AND THAT THE PAIN GETS CARRIED
BY OF THE COMMUNITY AND THE
POLICE OFFICER AND THE POLICE
INSTITUTION TO JUST CREATE
BIGGER BARRIERS AND MORE
DIVISIONS SO- I WOULD JUST SAY
HAVING ANOTHER OPERATOR HAVING
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEEP
RESTORATIVE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN POLICE POLICE OFFICERS
AND POLICE INSTITUTIONS. AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU FOR
THAT I WANT TO GO TO THE I WANT
TO GO TO THE- TO OUR CHIEF AND
THEN AFTER WHICH I WANT TO ASK
MISS YOU A QUESTION SO
HOPEFULLY SHE'S STILL STANDING
BY. CHIEF WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
DOING THAT WE'RE NOT DOING BY
WAY OF POLICY. TO TRY TO
ADDRESSSOME OF THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT EXIST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES
SO AS A MAN OF COLOR IN
LEADERSHIP IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHAT FROM YOUR LANDS AND SPACE
DID YOU DO YOU THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING TO TRY TO
BRIDGE THE GAP- ADDRESS ISSUES
THAT ARE NOT BEING ADDRESSED-
SO THAT THE COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN WORK.
COHESIVELY. LEAST DEVELOP A
BETTER RELATIONSHIP. SHARE
GIPSON THAT IS. A VERY VERY
QUICKLY AND WHAT I WILL SAY
BEFORE I GIVE YOU MY RESPONSE
IS WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THESE ISSUES WITH POLICING
COMMUNITY HE'S- IT IS JUST A
SYMPTOM OF WHAT IS OCCURRING IT
IN EVERY SITUATION IN OUR
COUNTRY. RIGHT WE ARE THE FACE
OF GOVERNMENT AND SO THE THINGS
THAT CAN MOST GO WRONG
TYPICALLY HAPPEN WHEN THOSE
INTERACTIONS TAKE PLACE BECAUSE
WE'RE ON THE COMMUNITIES BUT
EVERY SYSTEM. IN THE UNITED
STATES DISADVANTAGES PEOPLE OF
COLOR. WE HAVE TO DO IS GO BACK
AND LOOK ON A REPORT FROM THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND SOME OF
THE SAME THINGS THAT WERE
MENTIONED IN THAT REPORT. EXIST
TODAY. BUT IF YOU WERE TO ASK.
AND YOU DID WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DO I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS DOING IS. TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT. DEPARTMENTS
ARE MORE TRANSPARENT. BUT I
THINK REALLY THE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION AND I'VE SAID THIS TO
SOMEONE COLLEAGUES. IS HOW DO
YOU HOLD CHIEF. CHIEF OF POLICE
ACCOUNTABLE. BECAUSE THAT'S TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE. AT THE END
OF THE DAY. YOU CAN HAVE
POLICIES YOU CAN HAVE. LAWS ON
THE BOOKS YOU CAN HAVE TRAINING
BUT ULTIMATELY THE CHIEF.
CHANGES THE CULTURE SO HOW DO
YOU HOLD YOUR CHIEFS OF POLICE
ACCOUNTABLE. THAT IS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
DONE IF YOU TRULY WANT SYSTEMIC
CHANGE AT. ALL LEVELS. IN
ADDITION TO SOME OF THE THINGS
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED BECAUSE I
THINK THERE IS VALUE WILL BRING
THINGS TO PEOPLE'S ATTENTION
GIVEN THEM AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
RECOGNIZE. SOME OF THE BLIND
SPOTS. AND THEN. CREATE
INTERVENTION SO THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE AS MANY. AND THEY DON'T
IMPACT THE WAY THEY TREAT
PEOPLE BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE CHIEF. OF POLICE CHANGE
THE CULTURE IN AN ORGANIZATION
WHICH- INFORMED HOW OFFICERS
TREAT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND HOW DO WE DO THAT THAT'S
THE QUESTION. THANK YOU ALSO
FOLLOW QUESTION I'VE HEARD AND
I DARE NOT MENTION NAMES BUT
I'VE HEARD FROM POLICE CHIEFS
THAT THEIR HANDS ARE ARE ALMOST
TAG IN TERMS OF DEALING WITH A
BAD APPLE THAT MAY EXIST IN A
DEPARTMENT- DO YOU SHARE- THAT
SAME FEELING AND OR IF THERE'S
ANY SUGGESTIONS YOU CAN GIVE.
US THAT WE MAY BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT MOVING FORWARD. VERY
GOOD QUESTIONS ALSO THIS I'VE
GOT THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCE OF
HAVING WORKED IN ANOTHER STATE
THAT HAVE HAD- HAVING COME TO
CALIFORNIA. AND I'VE BEEN AN
EXECUTIVE FOR. ONE THIRD OF MY
CAREER SO ABOUT TWELVE YEARS
I'VE BEEN AT EITHER NUMBER TWO
IN A LARGE AGENCY. AND HERE IS
THE CHIEF. AND A SMALLER AGENCY.
MY HANDS ARE TIED NOW I CAN
UNDERSTAND FROM THE STANDPOINT
THEY FEEL IF SOMETHING GOES TO
ARBITRATION AND THE DECISION
THEY'VE MADE MAYBE GETS
OVERTURNED AND ARE IN
ARBITRATION THAT'S A SEPARATE
ISSUE I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT CAN
BE FRUSTRATING. AND I SEE THAT
AS AN IMPEDIMENT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME OFFICERS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'VE GOT AN
AVENUE. TO ADDRESS. ISSUES THAT
THEY FEEL MAYBE THEY WEREN'T
BEING TREATED FAIRLY IN. BUT MY
HANDS ARE TIED IF I WANT TO
TAKE A PARTICULAR ACTION
BECAUSE I BELIEVE VIOLATES
POLICY OR BELIEVE IT VIOLATES.
THE PHILOSOPHICAL APPROACH AND
I THINK OUR OFFICERS SHOULD BE
EMBODYING. I CAN HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE MY HANDS ARE TIED.
NOW I NEED TO MAKE SURE I HAVE
A STRONG ENOUGH CASE SO THAT
THE LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING
OVERTURNED IS REDUCED BUT THE
FACT IS NONE OF US HAVE A
CRYSTAL BALL AND YOU CAN HAVE
THE STRONGEST CASE IN THE WORLD
AND I CAN STLL GET OVER HER.
MY HANDS ARE TIED SO I WOULD BE
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
EXAMPLES ARE BECAUSE MY HANDS
WERE TIED WHEN I WAS IN TEXAS
NOT. TIED HERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT. I WANT TO GO TO-
MISS YOU- IF YOU'RE STILL WITH
US. AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
WE MAY HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION I
DON'T KNOW BUT PLEASE STAND BY
I MISS YOU I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU- WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON AS IT RELATES TO RE
IMAGINING AND I USE THE WORD-
REIMAGINE ALSO REFORM
INTERCHANGEABLY BUT WE'RE GOING
TO REIMAGINE WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOOKS LIKE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID WHAT ARE SOME
OF WHAT CAN YOU GIVE ME THREE-
PARTICULAR AREAS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE FOCUSING
ON TO TRY TO HELP AND REIMAGINE
WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT LOOKS LIKE
IN THIS STATE. FROM YOUR LANDS.
SURE SO THERE HAS BEEN A THEME
HERE TODAY IT'S REALLY ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THESE REFORMS YOU
HAVE A COUPLE OF ISSUES. ONE I
EASE IN SB TWO ONE TWO IN
FRONT. OF ONE OF THE WITH
ISSUES. IT HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
DECERTIFICATION WE ARE NOW ONLY
ONE OF FOUR STATES THAT DO NOT
HAVE A PROCESS. IN DEALING WITH
POLICE OFFICERS WHO BREAK THE
LAW. SO IT REALLY IS
UNACCEPTABLE BUT ALL THESE
OTHER STATES HAVE A WAY TO DEAL
WITH THEIR OFFICERS AND TREAT
THEM AS PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY
ARE. BUT WE DO NOT SO THAT
REALLY IS ONE WAY TO MAKE. IT
TRANSPARENT. AND YOU HAVE-
ACCOUNTABILITY BY THE OFFICERS.
THE SECOND ISSUE AS WE TALKED
ABOUT ARE THESE IMMUNITIES THE
WAY THAT WE TREAT THE VICTIMS.
OF POLICE VIOLENCE SO
DIFFERENTLY. THAN WE DO THE
OFFICERS THEMSELVES. IS
UNSPEAKABLE AND EXPAND THE
CLEAR MESSAGE AGAIN AND AGAIN
TO EVERYBODY WITHIN THE STATE.
THAT SOME PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE
TREATED BETTER SOME PEOPLE GET
SPECIAL TREATMENT FROM THE
JUDGES. OUT FROM THEIR OWN
DEPARTMENTS FROM THE POPULAR.
CHILDHOOD VICTIMS HAVE NOWHERE
TO GO NO ONE TO TALK TO YOU. I
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT IN
LOOKING AT SB TOOTH THAT BOTH
PROVISIONS. AND ARE LOOKED AT
VERY CAREFULLY BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THE REPRESENT WIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND.
TRANSPARENCY CAN LEAD TO. THANK
YOU WERE COMPLETE. YES OKAY
CORRECT THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH FOR THAT HI I HEAR YOU
KNOW A COMMON THEME IN TERMS OF
A TRANSPARENCY AND I THINK
THAT. WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM BOTH
SIDES PEOPLE WANT TO BE
TRANSPARENT IN THIS PARTICULAR
PROCESS AND SO WE CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT AND
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ARE MOVING
THROUGH THE LESS THAT PROCESS
RIGHT NOW THAT SPEAKS TO A MORE
TRANSPARENT- PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT BEING SAID-
ONE **** ON MY COLLEAGUES HE
HAS ANY COMMENTS OR REMARKS TO
MAKE OKAY. WE HAVE NO CAR I
DON'T ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE LINE I MISS THE STYLUS OR
ANYONE THAT HAS ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE WE MOVED TO OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION. IN A CELL
PLEASE FREE TO- JUST CHIME
RIGHT ON IN. OKAY HEARING AND
SAYING NO ONE IN THE QUEUE I
WANT TO AGAIN EXPRESS MY
DEEPEST GRATITUDE AND THANKS
TO- THE- THE OUR PANELISTS FOR
COMING OUT AND FOR BEING PART
OF THIS DIALOGUE- HOW DO WE- DO
THE WORK WE WERE TRYING OUR
BEST. AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON FOR
GIVING US THE SPACE TO HAVE
THIS OPEN DIALOGUE- AS I
INDICATED WE'VE DONE A NUMBER
OF HEARINGS- HAVE HAD GREAT
TESTIMONIES ON BOTH SIDES WE
TRY NOT TO LEAVE ANY VOICES OUT
OF THIS PROCESS- WE HOPE THAT
WE'LL HAVE MAYBE ANOTHER ONE OR
OUR- COUPLE MORE AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. BUT THIS
TIME THIS IS THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION- WE WOULD ASK AGAIN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- ONE TO
LIMIT YOUR REMARKS TO TWO
MINUTES. THERE IS A MICROPHONE-
THIS BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS WE
ASK THAT YOU APPROACH- THAT
MICROPHONE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
OF PLEASE WE ASK THAT YOU DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
SERGEANTS WILL IN FACT MAKE THE
ADJUSTMENT ON THE MICROPHONE.
SO AT THIS TIME WE WILL INVITE
ANYONE OF THE PUBLIC AN
OPPORTUNITY WILL TAKE THOSE IN
THE AUDIENCE FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE TO THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WAITING ON
LINE- FIRST. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID ANYONE REMEMBER THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC.
TESTIMONY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
APPROACH TO THE MICROPHONE
BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS. AND YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES BUT YOUR
REMARKS AND WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR A HEARING TO THE
RULES OF DECORUM- THAT OUTLINED
REGARDING- SOCIAL AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING- AND ONE PERSON IN
THE ELEVATOR SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID IF YOU COULD PLEASE TATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN PROCEED
WITH YOUR COMMENTS. HELLO MY
NAME IS JACK SHELLS AND- SO I
KIND OF WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT- I HAVE BEEN USING THIS
YEAR'S AMOUNT PLEASE- WE'RE
WE'RE HAVING SOME DISTURBANCE
UP IN THE BALCONY. WOULD YOU
PLEASE- CONDUCT YOURSELF TO THE
RULES OF THE DECORUM. MA'AM IF
YOU CAN PLEASE AGAIN- PLEASE
QUIET DOWN- SOMEONE IS GIVING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND YOU CAN'T
DO THAT THEN I WOULD HAVE TO BE
FORCED ASKS I WANT TO START
JUST A SCORCHER OUT. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. PLEASE
BEGAN START ALL OVER. STATE
YOUR NAME THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JACK SHELLS. AND I HAVE BEEN ON
BOTH ENDS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE POSITIVE AND THE NEGATIVE
ENDING A BIT NEGATIVE AND- AND
I KNOW WITH THE COMMUNITY. WE
DO A LOT OF- WELL THERE'S A
POLICE ACTIVITY LEAGUE. YOU IT
THERE'S LIKE DIFFERENT RANKS
FOR ARE. FOR OUR CHILDREN TO BE
INVOLVED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO KNOW THEM MORE TO KNOW
BETTER THE RELATIONSHIPS. AND
THIS SEEMS TO REALLY HELP WITH
MY TOWN I'M FROM CITRUS
HEIGHTS. AND THE SMALLER I
GUESS THE SMALLER THE TOWN IS.
THE MORE OPPORTUNITIES YOU HAVE
TO KNOW LAW ENFORCEMENT- IS SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE THING THAT I
THINK. WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE WITH- SACRAMENTO. IS
MORE OF THE COMMUNITY TO REACH
OUT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS AND START
KNOWING MORE OF THE LAWS. AND
ALSO I KNOW THAT- THERE ARE FEW
OFFICERS WHO DO HAVE
CONSEQUENCES. OF THEIR ACTIONS
IT'S JUST. NOT POSTED UP ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. I SO THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT I WANTED TO SAY
AND I KNOW WITH MY EXPERIENCE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT BACK IN
STOCKTON. I HAVE- BEEN ARRESTED
BEFORE AND I DID ADMIT MY
CRIME. AND I WAS RELEASED AND
THAT CASE IS CLOSED I MOVED
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. NEW LIFE
NEW FRESH START AND- I DO
RESPECT LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND
BUT I THINK HAVING CERTAIN
PROGRAMS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO REACH OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
REALLY DOES HELP- SO THE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO HAVE THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND
START KNOWING EACH OTHER
BETTER. AND IF YOU HAVE AN
ISSUE WITH WHATEVER YOU CAN GO
TO A CERTAIN OFFICER TALK AND
THEN THEY'LL TELL YOU WHAT YOU
NEED TO DO. AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S BASICALLY ALL I WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THAT- THANK YOU FOR
SHARING. YOUR THOUGHTS WITH US-
AGAIN THIS IS THE TIME FOR THE
PUBLIC- COMMENT WE WOULD SIMPLY
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. PLEASE REFER. STATE
YOUR NAME FOR WHICH OUR
COMMENTS- WE'RE DOING WELL WHAT
TIMES ARE BEING A LITTLE BIT
LIBERAL WITH TIME WITHOUT
PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION SO SIR
PLEASE. FEEL FREE. TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE NEEDED
ADJUSTED WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ADJUST IT FOR YOU.
SEEMS A LITTLE BIT LOW OKAY ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
NAME IS TIMOTHY WEEKS AND-
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO I WAS AT A
RALLY IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
AND- THE FOOD THERE WAS A
POLICE. PRESENCE THERE THAT-
WERE ON BICYCLES RIGHT NEXT TO
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. AND WE
NOTICED THERE WAS A PARADE OF
ANTIFA MARCHERS THAT WERE
MARCHING DOWN IN ST AND WE HAD
PARKED OUR VEHICLE IN IN ST
UNFORTUNATELY AND WE HEARD THIS
CROWD THE ANTIFA MARCHERS WERE
BASHING IN CAR WINDOWS AND
TEARING OFF- SIDE MIRRORS AND
SLASHING TIRES AND AS THEY
STARTED TO APPROACH THE POLICE
WORK MAINTAINING QUITE A
DISTANCE FROM THESE MARCHERS
AND THEY TOLD US THAT WE SHOULD
NOT PASS BY THE POLICE
OTHERWISE THEY CANNOT GUARANTEE
OUR SAFETY. AND I SAID WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY DESTROY MY
VEHICLE- AND THEY SAID WELL IF
WE SEE IT WE CAN ARREST THEM
BUT THEY WERE BASICALLY WAITING
A WHOLE BLOCK BEHIND THE
MARCHERS SO THERE WAS NO WAY
FOR THEM TO SEE- ANY KIND OF
VANDALISM AGAINST VEHICLES. AND
IT BOTHERED ME THAT. I FELT
SOMEWHAT UNPROTECTED BY OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND I HAVE A
FEELING IT'S BECAUSE THEY WERE.
TOLD TO STAND DOWN. AGAINST
THESE- MARCHERS- AND IT BOTHERS
ME THAT I FEEL LIKE ARE THE
HANDS OF THE POLICE ARE TIED IN
MANY WAYS- I FELT UNSAFE I ONLY
FELT SAFE WHEN I WAS STANDING
RIGHT NEXT TO THE POLICE
OFFICERS. IT IT BOTHERED ME
THAT THEY HAD TO WAIT I DON'T
KNOW WHY THEY WAITED BUT THEY
WAITED A WHOLE BLOCK BEHIND THE
MARCHERS SO WHEN WE WENT TO OUR
CAR TO DETER DETERMINE. SKEWS
ME TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
OUR VEHICLE HAD BEEN VANDALIZED
OURS WAS NOT BUT THREE OTHER
VEHICLES RIGHT NEAR OUR
VEHICLES WERE. SMASHED AND
PEOPLE WERE STANDING AT THEIR
VEHICLES CRYING WATCHING
LOOKING AT THEIR DAMAGED
VEHICLES AND- IT BOTHERED ME
THAT. THAT THE POLICE OFFICERS
WOULD ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN- TWO
VEHICLES THEY MIGHT OF
PROTECTED HIM THE PEOPLE
THEMSELVES BUT THEIR VEHICLES
WERE AND PROTECTED AND I FELT
LIKE. OUR POLICEMEN ARE IN
WOMEN ARE THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
IN DOING THEIR JOBS AND I FEEL
LIKE. THERE IS THE THEY HAVE TO
DANCE AROUND ALL THESE LITTLE
RULES AND EVERYTHING TO TRY TO
NOT- UPSET PEOPLE AND- IT'S-
IT'S LIKE THEY CAN'T EVEN DO
THEIR JOBS WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE LITTLE THING
THEY DO I CANNOT A MAN OF THE
MATCH IN THE MENA STRESSED THAT
THEY- HAVE TO DEAL WITH EVERY
DAY IN THEIR IN THEIR JOBS. AND
STILL THEY HAVE TO BE SO
CAREFUL THAT THEY DON'T. MAKE A
LITTLE MISTAKE AND OFFEND
SOMEONE AND HURT SOMEONE- IT
AND SOME PEOPLE THEY THEY
RESIST ARREST INSTEAD INSTEAD
OF JUST COOPERATING WITH THE
POLICE THEY RESIST AND THAT.
THAT JUST EXACERBATES THE
PROBLEM AND I FEEL LIKE IF
PEOPLE JUST OBEY WHAT THE
POLICEMAN SAYS OUR POLICE WOMAN
SAYS AND GO ALONG WITH THEM
YOU'LL HAVE YOUR DAY IN COURT
IF THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING
WRONG BUT IF YOU RESIST THAT'S
WHEN YOU'RE LIKELY. TO BE- TO
BE BRUTALIZED IF YOU WILL
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE. IT'S
SOMETHING WITH ANY HUMAN BEING
THAT IF YOU IF YOU FIGHT THEM.
THEY'RE GONNA FIGHT BACK AND I
FEEL LIKE. A LOT OF TIMES THESE
VICTIMS DAVE THEY RESIST ARREST
OR THEY RESIST THE POLICE
OFFICER INSTEAD OF JUST. A THE
BILL OBEYING THEM IN A SENSE IF
SOMEONE IF A POLICE OFFICER TO
COME TO ME AND I'M AS WHITE AS
WHITE COULD BE. I GET THAT I
CAN NEVER UNDERSTAND HOW IT'S
GOING TO BE FOR A PERSON OF
COLOR. BUT IF A POLICE OFFICER
ASKED ME TO DO SOMETHING I
WOULD OBEY THEM I WOULD NOT
RESIST THEM BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE STE JUST BE FOOLISHNESS NO
MATTER WHAT COLOR WHAT SHADE OF
SKIN YOU ARE YOU JUST DON'T
RESIST THEM BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PURPOSE IN THAT. YOU OBEY THEM
AND YOU DO WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO BECAUSE THEY ARE AN
AUTHORITY AND THEY HAVE A VERY
STRESSFUL JOB AND WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THERE'S COMPLETE
STRESS ALL THE TIME ON THEM
THIRTY SECONDS. AND I'M
FINISHED THANK YOU KNOW THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY- I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S ANOTHER- MEMBER THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK- WE
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE- PLEASE
DON'T TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT- WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR VIDEO-
STATION OUTSIDE IN SERVICE
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND IN
PER SE WHICH ARE COMMON. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. JULIA STILES YES
YEAH PLEASE PROCEED YEAH THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY
THANK YOU LET ME SPEAK TODAY-
WHAT I LEARNED ABOUT AB SIX IS
FIVE IS THAT I LEARNED THAT
IT'S TO FIND POTENTIAL HATE
GROUPS WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND I THINK THIS BILL. THE LIST
WHERE I WRITE IS VERY SLIPPERY
SLOPE BECAUSE YOU WANT TO. VOTE
OUT THE HATE GROUP OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED THE HATE
GROUP BUT THE QUESTION COMES
DOWN TO WHO WITH THE HATE GROUP
IN WHAT IS A HATE GROUP. AND
WHEN YOU LABEL THINGS SPECIAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS WEISS A PER
ME SI OVER INTO VICE DIPLOMACY
WORLD THINGS VERY DANGEROUS
VISUAL LABEL AND EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN LAW ENFORCEMENT. A
SUPREME IS BASED ON COLOR SKIN
AND BY DEFINITION THAT WOULD BE
RACES. SO I THINK THIS BILL IS
A VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE BECAUSE
IT TARGETS A CERTAIN PEOPLE
EVEN THOUGH IT'S SAID TO BE
CLAIM THAT IT'S NOT IT REALLY
IS TARGETING A GROUP OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE WHO BECOMES A HATE
GROUP CHRISTIANS. PRO LIFERS
ANYBODY THT HAS A RELIGION
THAT GOES AGAINST THE
NARRATIVE. WHO DO WE START
DEMAND WHO'S I HATE GROUP AND
WHO'S NOT. SO I THINK THIS IS A
VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE I THINK.
YOU SHOULD REALLY TINK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING WITH THIS
BILL. COULD YOU CAN BE
POTENTIALLY TARGETING PEOPLE.
AND THAT CREATES MORE DIVISION
THAN IN DIS UNITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR COMMENT WE
APPRECIATE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INPUT- NEXT IS THERE ANOTHER AN
AUDIENCE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
AND PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME YES
MA'AM. HI IF YOU GET CLOSER TO
THE MICROPHONE WILL ADJUST IT
DOWN SO YOU CAN SEE. THANK YOU.
YES AB I'M NICOLE YANG AND I'D-
I OFFER MY CONDOLENCES TO THE
FAMILY I WAS HERE TODAY. I WE
HAVE MILITARIZED OUR POLICE
SYSTEM. AND NOT TO SAY THAT
THERE AREN'T POINTS IN THAT
SYSTEM THAT. NEED
MILITARIZATION BUT AS FAR AS
THE MENTAL HEALTH BECAUSE
MENTAL HEALTH IS A HUGE ISSUE.
IN TODAY'S SOCIETY AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE. ARE WALKING AROUND WITH
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THEY'RE LOOKED UPON WITH A LOT
OF FEAR AND SO MAYBE. WITHIN
THAT BILL COULD WE INCLUDE MORE
TRAINING. FOR POLICE OFFICERS
TO DEAL WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
RAVAGED BY MENTAL ILLNESS AT. I
AM I MYSELF HAVE FAMILY MEMBER
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER WHO
SUFFERS FROM MENTAL ILLNESS AND
HAS SUFFERED GREATLY AT THE
HANDS OF. THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT. OUR POLICE OFFICERS
AND. AS PAINFUL AS THAT IS A
FAMILY MEMBER TO WATCH I
UNDERSTAND THE POSITION OF THE
POLICE OFFICERS. BUT I DO THINK
THERE NEEDS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE TRAINING. AND THAT IN THAT
FIELD AND THAT'S ALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMA
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. WE HAVE A
NUMBER AND ANOTHER MEMBER OF
THE- THE PUBLIC WHO WILL BE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE WE
JUST ASK THAT YOU. A STEP
BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS DON'T
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. ANY
MEMBER FEEL FREE IF YOU'VE
COMPLETED YOUR COMMENTS YOU CAN
PLEASE OF EXIT THE MEETING
ROMAN PLEASE ONE PERSON
ELEVATOR AT A TIME SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US AND
PLEASE PROCEED. YES OKAY HI
THANK YOU FOR TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SAY THAT WE HEARD FROM A BLM
REPRESENTATIVE EARLIER. AND SHE
WAS SAYING THAT BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES NEED TO STOP LIKING
FORTIES AND NEEDTO STOP
ELEVATING THEM. AND THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE PUNISHMENT FOR
POLICE OFFICERS. THIS IS THE
KIND OF RHETORIC OF HATE THAT
LEADS TO MORE VIOLENCE AND TO
MORE MOTIVATING MORE TOLD
POLICE OFFICERS. WHOSE LIVES
MATTER JUST AS MUCH AS EVERYONE
ELSE'S LIVES. THIS IS THE KIND
OF RHETORIC THAT IS VERY
DANGEROUS THERE NEEDS TO BE
LESS HATE TOWARDS POLICE
OFFICERS AND MORE SUPPORT AND
TRAINING GIVEN TO THEM THEY HAD
JUST AS MUCH HUMANS AS ALL OF
US. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YEAH SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE ONE MORE MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK AND
BE HEARD ON THIS MATTER. OKAY
NO PROBLEM.
WE HAVE ONE MORE
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK THAT PERSON WILL BE
ENTERING THE ROOM AND A MOMENT.
OKAY. HELLO DON'T YOU THINK. MY
CLAVICLE ISN'T TALKING BUT I
KNOW I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE ONE MOMENT THE
VIRUS WITH THE NINETY NINE
POINT 9% SURVIVAL RATE OH WAIT
WRONG HEARING THIS IS POLICE
REFORM. I HAVE A POLICE STORY
MYSELF. I WAS IN A CROWD OF
THOUSANDS OF PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS LAST MAY FIRST.
PEOPLE WHO WANTED THEIR
BUSINESSES OPEN PEOPLE WHO
WANTED SCHOOL FOR THEIR
CHILDREN RIGHT HERE ON THE LAWN
OF THE CAPITOL. WHEN YOU
UNLEASH C. H. P. ON US AND
THIRTY TWO OF US WERE
UNLAWFULLY ARRESTED. BECAUSE WE
WANT THE RIGHT TO BE FREE. WE
WANT THE RIGHT TO ACCESS OUR
OWN HOUSE THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE
MISS HOUSE MY FRIENDS HAD
BRUISES ON THEIR BODIES MOTHERS
IN A CROWD HIT BY BATONS. AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT POLICE
REFORM IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
MAYBE YOU HAVE AN INTERNAL
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED BECAUSE MY FOUR KIDS
WATCHED ME ARRESTED THAT DAY
FOR PEACEFULLY HOLDING A SIGN.
ON THE LAWN OF THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE WHERE WE HAD BEEN
WELCOMED FOUR HOURS. AND
THEY'RE TERRORIZED MY NINE YEAR
OLD WILL NOT COME TO THIS
BUILDING IT SCARES HIM TOO MUCH.
SO WHICH SIDE OF YOUR MOUTH ARE
YOU GOING TO TALK OUT OF NEXT.
THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE YOU
WORK FOR US AND YOU HAVE SOLD A
MOTHER TODAY TRYING TO GET HER
THREE CHILDREN IN BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T WEAR CARCINOGENIC
MASKS. YOU TOLD ME THIS HEARING
IS FULL THIRTY SECONDS THERE'S
AT LEAST. THE EMPTY SEATS. AND
YOU THINK WHERE THE PROBLEM.
OPEN THIS CAPITAL IMMEDIATELY.
THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE THAT'S
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM AND
THE PEOPLE KNOW THE TRUTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS THIS
BODY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING HEARING NONE. WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS. LET
ME SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL THE PRESENTERS- IN ALL OF
OUR SPEAKERS SUCH A HARD ME
MISTER CHAIR THE CAMPAIGN
OPERATOR WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
ON THE LINE PLEASE I APOLOGIZE
PLEASE LET THE MAN. AND AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE AS WELL MATURE WE DO
HAVE ONE PERSON WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK AND IF ANYONE ELSE IS ON
THE PHONE LINES THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK HERO GOOD MORNING- MY
NAME IS ARE THESE ON I AM A
COMMUNITY NEAR A LIFT AN ARTS
EDUCATOR- I HAVE A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOU
BEING BEING- OUT RESCUE AND
ALSO WITH INCARCERATED HERE
INSIDE OF BUT YOU CAN OPT OUT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BEGAN BY
GIVING MY CONDOLENCES. TO THE
FAMILY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SHARING YOUR VERY MOVING
TESTIMONY TODAY IT WAS VERY.
I'M JUST WANTED TO SHARE
SOMETHING VERY BRIEFLY AT THE
QUICK TESTIMONY- I THINK YOUR
LIP WORKING INSIDE OF JUVENILE
HALL. IN TWENTY NINETEEN I HAVE
A YOUNG LADY WHO WERE GOING TO
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING HOME AND SHE HAD
TOLD ME ALL YOU KNOW I'M I'M
SORRY I'M LEAVING I WILL BE
ABLE TO FINISH THE MEAL AND I
WAS LIKE HONEYCOMB AND NEVER
COME BACK TO THE GIVEN ALL YOU
KNOW. IT'S GONNA GET YOUR ACT
TOGETHER AND YOU KNOW TAKE CARE
OF YOURSELF AND SHE ASKED ME
SHE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
YOU DO IF YOU CAME ON THE
ORIGINAL KIT. AND I SAID WELL
THAT WOULD BE A DAY OF
CELEBRATION BECAUSE I MEAN
THERE'S NO INCARCERATED. YOUTH
HOCKEY ANGELES. AND CARPET WAS
WERE. WITH THE- INTO. THEM
WOULDN'T HAVE A JOB. AND I SAID
SURE YOU WAY. YOU COULD DO THAT
YOU KNOW SECURITY OR- ANY KIND
OF FACILITATOR AT AN ARTS
CENTER WE CAN TURN THE PLACE
INTO AN ART. CENTER SO I JUST
WANT TO ADD TO THIS
CONVERSATION. AND REALLY GIVE
THANKS TO EVERYBODY WHO DID
POINT OUT THAT THIS IS A
CULTURAL ISSUE S WELL AS-
SYSTEMIC ISSUE. BUT WE NEED TO
START. THINKING DIFFERENTLY.
ABOUT CRIMINALIZATION AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO.
YOU GROWING UP I WAS A CRIMINAL
LIFE YEAR. AND I WAS ABLE TO
GET MYSELF OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND BECOME SOMEBODY WHO WOULD
BE ABOUT THE CHECK. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR YOU. TO DO THAT. AND EVER
SINCE- YOU KNOW THE-
PROPOSITIONS THAT WERE POSSIBLY
BY PETE WILSON. THAT HAVE
INCREASINGLY CRIMINALIZED YOUTH
WHICH IS SEEN- AN INCREASE IN.
THE OVERALL. CONDITION. THAT WE
HAVE A LOS ANGELES. THIS
CONDITION COMES POVERTY AND HOW
FROM- YOU KNOW TOLD MICHAEL
MUNICIPAL. THAT REALLY LED TO-
GAME PROP. THAT WE- TO REVEAL
AT SO I JUST WANT. TO THINK
ABOUT. BRINGING SOME CREATIVE
SENSE OF CONVERSATION BRINGING
SOME YOU INTO THE CONVERSATION
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR. SOME KIDS
IN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE OR YOU CAN
NOT BOTH THAT HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THE SYSTEM IN THE CONVERSATION
AS WELL AS SOME POLICE OFFICER.
SECOND COMING FROM THE POSITION
I'M COMING FROM IT IS DIFFICULT
TO SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
OFFICERS- YOU KNOW. FEELING I
PRESSED ANY SITUATION BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE ONES WITH ALL THE
POWER THEY'RE THE ONES WITH
GUNS POINTING GUNS AT A FORMER
CHILDREN. SO THIS IS SOMETHING
TO DEFINITELY THINK ABOUT THIS
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO BE
EXPANDED. IT'S GREAT THAT WE
HAVE THIS I'D APPRECIATE IT BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF PRIVILEGED
VOICES IN THE CONVERSATION AND
WE NEED TO HAVE THE COMP WE
NEED TO HAVE THE VOICES OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. RARELY
REPRESENTED OR NOT REPRESENTED
ONLY THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT.
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE TO
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE OF SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK WE'RE
GOING. TO GO TO LINE THIRTEEN.
ONE THIRTEEN REMINDERS OPEN.
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOANNA HEDRICK. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES OKAY THANKS- I AM A-
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT HAVE LIVED
HERE ALL MY LIFE I AM A LAW
ABIDING CITIZEN AND I SUPPORT
THE POLICE I BELIEVE THAT THERE
CAN BE. BAD APPLES IN EVERY-
LINE OF EMPLOYMENT AND I THINK
THAT PEOPLE. ARE YOU DOING
REFORM ON BAD TEACHERS OR BAD
STAFF MEMBERS THAT OTHER JOB OR
BAD POLITICIANS NO WE DON'T
HAVE THAT WE JUST HAVE THIS
FOCUS ON BAD LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE ALREADY
HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE THAT DEAL
WITH. LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEY
DO THINGS THAT ARE ON
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVICTIONS IT
SOUNDED LIKE FROM WHEN I WAS
LISTENING TO THE HEARING THAT
THERE WAS ALREADY THOSE THINGS
IN PLACE. SO WHAT IS IT THAT
YOU'RE PERFORMING- I WATCHED
THIS WHOLE LAST SUMMER. AS
PEOPLE WERE PROTESTING SMASHING
A BUSINESSES THE VEHICLE ON
INDUSTRY. AND NOTHING NOTHING
HAPPENS TO THEM BUT THEN WHEN
WE'RE OUT THERE PEACEFULLY
PROTEST SEEMS TO OPEN UP THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO YOU
DON'T HAVE. PEOPLE OUT OF THE
JOB WE GET ARRESTED FOR THAT I
YOU KNOW WITNESS TO ALL THESE
PEOPLE GET ARRESTED FOR
STANDING THERE WITH A FINE
ASKING TO OPEN UP CALIFORNIA
YET YOU DO NOTHING TO ALL THE
PEOPLE PRO TESTING. BLM AND
ANTIFA PEOPLE NATIONAL
BUSINESSES MAKING THINGS WORSE
LAKE I JUST DON'T GET IT AND I
WOULD LOVE TO READ MORE ABOUT
WHAT THIS REFORM ACTUALLY IS.
AND TALK ABOUT HOW YOU WILL
FORM EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST COLOR IT'S- I
LIKE THE LAST COLOR ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS CALLER THIRTY THERE
YOU HAVE THIRTY SECONDS. IF
YOU'LL LISTEN TO THE COPS AND
ABIDE BY WHAT THEY'RE SAYING.
YOU DON'T GET TO BE A VICTIM
LIKE THIS PEOPLE TAKE CONTROL
OF YOUR OWN LIVES AND BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR ACTIONS
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OPERATORS ARE
ANOTHER CALL. OPERATOR DEFINITE
A CALL THANK YOU. ALL. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YES HI MY NAME IS
JULIAN RANDALL I'M AN AMERICAN
HISTORIAN EDUCATOR
CONSTITUTIONALIST I HAVE MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND THE
TERM PRIVILEGE IS GETTING NOT
EATING MORE BY THE DAY SO THAT
PREVIOUS CALLER WHO TALK CAN'T
TALK ABOUT PRIVILEGE PRIVILEGE
PRIVILEGED WE'RE TIRED OF THAT
ALREADY IT'S NOT IT COULD BE TO
KNOW WHERE MY NEPHEW AND UNCLE
AND FAMILY MEMBERS TO OUR
POLICE OFFICERS ARE NOT
PRIVILEGED HE THEY WENT THROUGH
INTENSE TRAINING THEY GET UP
EVERY DAY AND THEY PUT ON THAT
BADGE AND THEY GO OUT THERE TO
SAVE LIVES AND THEY GO OUT TO
THEIR TO PROTECT PEOPLE. AND SO
TO VIEW OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
IT'S PRIVILEGE THEY HAVE A
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
WHY DON'T THEY INVEST ABOUT
THAT TO THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
WEALTHY WHO'S REALLY PRIVILEGED
BLACK LIVES MATTER IT'S
PRIVILEGE MY NEPHEW AND MY
UNCLE WHO SERVICE VALIANTLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY WHEN. NOT
SHOULD'VE VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE
ON WHO IS THE ARBITER OF A HATE
GROUP BECAUSE THIS IS OPEN FOR
LITIGATION ALREADY AND I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHO
THE ARBITERS OF TRUTH ARE HERE
BUT WHAT SOME PEOPLE MIGHT SEE
AS A HATE GROUP IS NOT. AND
THOSE PEOPLE WHO THINK THAT
THEY'RE SO RIGHTEOUS THAT THEY
CAN LABEL HATE GROUPS ARE THE
ONES WHO THIS WILL TURN ON VERY
VERY QUICKLY SO THIS IS THAT
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS POLICE
REFORM BILL- THAT I THINK IS
MADE IN GREAT HASTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATORS THERE
ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK. SURE THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
TEAM PUBLIC COMMENT. OF CLOSE
AT THIS POINT IN TIME I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE SPEAKERS FOR
PROVIDING THEIR INSIGHT
REGARDING THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES I HOPE THAT YOU WERE
ABLE TO GAIN INSIGHT TODAY'S
REGARDING THE COMMUNITY IMPACT.
OF OFFICERS A BAD JUDGMENT AND
WHAT TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE TO
PROVIDE RECOVERY THIS ISN'T
ABOUT ATTACKING ALL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT IT'S ABOUT
PUSHING THEM TO DO BETTER
BECAUSE THE IMPACT GOES FAR
BEYOND THE VICTIMS OF
MISCONDUCT COMMUNITIES. HAVE TO
REBUILD AND LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
TO FIND WAYS TO REGAIN THE
COMMUNITIES TRUST AFTER EVERY.
INCIDENT NOT JAZZ- THOSE YOU
READ ABOUT OR SEE- GOING VIRAL
ON SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WE
WILL CONTINUE TO EXPAND ON
TOPICS LIKE THIS IN ORDER TO
EXPOSE SOLUTIONS. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF THEIR BUSY SCHEDULE
OF GOOD FRIDAY BEING HERE
VIRTUALLY AND THOSE WHO ARE
PRESENT BECAUSE CONFLICT
NINETEEN- NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
PRESENT TODAY. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON FOR MAKING THIS ALL
POSSIBLE ALLOWING US TO BE IN
THIS SPACE TO HAVE THIS OPEN
PUBLIC DIALOGUE. AROUND PLEASE
REFORM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE WORKED ON
MULTIPLE. ON MULTIPLE HEARINGS.
OVER THE LAST YEAR THAT HAVE
ADDICTS SIGNIFICANTLY TO OF THE
LEGISLATURE DEVELOPMENT OF
POLICIES REFORM LEGISLATION
TODAY THERE ARE ALREADY ABOUT
TWENTY TWO. PIECES OF
LEGISLATION OR POLICE REFORM
BILLS GOING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE. SIMILARLY WE
ARE HOPING TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
THAT HAVE TAKEN THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO SERVE AND PROTECT OUR
TRULY SERVING AND PROTECTING.
THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BROUGHT MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES TO THE TABLE EVEN
WHEN THOSE INVOLVED ARE NOT IN
AGREEMENT BECAUSE WE MUST ALL
WORK TOGETHER- TO CHANNEL AND
FIND SOLUTIONS TO THIS ISSUE
THAT FACE- THE STATE. THESE
CHANGES DEMAND SOBRE
UNDERSTANDING ADD A WILLINGNESS
TO HEAR OPPOSITE SIDES OF YOU
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BODY HAS-
ENDEAVOR ITSELF TO PUT SPEAKERS
AND EXPERTS IN COMMUNITY- AT
THE TABLE TO HAVE AND LET THEIR
VOICES BE HEARD IN THIS SPACE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO HOTEL
HOLDING MORE HEARINGS THIS YEAR-
TO COME TO SOME KIND OF
CONCLUSION BY WAY OF OUR WORK.
BEFORE I JOURNAL I WANT TO ASK
MY COLLEAGUE IF HE HAS ANY
CLOSING REMARKS- BEFORE WE DO
BEFORE DOING SO. MR LACKEY NO I
THINK THAT- THIS ISSUE IS VERY
SENSITIVE BUT VERY VERY.
IMPORTANT FOR US TO COME TO
SOME KIND OF REASONABLE.
CONCLUSION AND- I THINK WE JUST
NEED TO BE VERY VRY CAUTIOUS
THAT WE DON'T OR CASTIGATE. A
PROFESSION IN A NEGATIVE LIGHT-
AND TO FIND A WHOLE PROFESSION
BY THE- INAPPROPRIATE ACTIONS
OF A FEW AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE PARTICIPATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MEMBER LACKEY-
BAYERN RUSKIN SAID THERE'S LET
US. BE IN H. I'M IN A RAGE BACK
IN JUST AS BUT LET US NOT BE
DESTROYED BY IT. AND THAT'S
JUST THE WAY OF US WORKING
TOGETHER SO THAT WE CAN- GET
THE JUSTICE THAT WE'RE SEEKING-
BY REAL DIALOGUE ON BOTH SIDES
SO WE CAN REACH SOME
RESOLUTIONS AND SOLUTIONS. TO
THE PROBLEMS THAT FACE US ALL I
WANT TO THANK. OUR A NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE- THE
SERGEANTS FOR BEING HERE MY
TEAM TEAM GIVES A MISTAKE WHY
DON'T EVERYONE FOR TAKING THE
TIME OUT THEIR BUSY SCHEDULE
AND BEING HERE TODAY ON THIS
GOOD FRIDAY WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE INPUT. FROM ALL OF OUR
PANEL- AND THAT CONCLUDES THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.